la séance est ouverte et chers collègues
nous achevons une nouvelle série
d'auditions avec monsieur benalla puis
monsieur kraz je vous rappelle notre
mandat d'une part apprécié les
conditions dans lesquelles des personnes
étrangères aux forces de sécurité ont pu
ou peuvent être associés à l'exercice
des missions de maintien de l'ordre ou
de protection de hautes personnalités en
l'occurrence le président de la
république et d'autre part vérifier la
portée des sanctions prononcées en cas
de manquement tout at il été mis en
oeuvre pour les appliquer correctement
à ce titre nous avons interrogé monsieur
benalla au mois de septembre dernier sur
la nature exacte de ses fonctions à
l'elysée et en particulier sur l'étendue
de sa mission tant sur l'organisation et
le fonctionnement général de la sécurité
du président de la république que sur la
protection rapprochée du chef de l'état
sauf s'il souhaite lui même revenir sur
ces différents points
il n'est sans doute pas indispensable de
poser de nouvelles questions dans ce
domaine nous ne refaisons pas l'audition
de septembre nous avions aussi interrogé
monsieur mais dallas sur la réalité de
la sanction qui lui auraient été
infligées en mai 2018 après les fautes
commises lors des manifestations du 1er
mai à paris et sur l'application de la
mesure de licenciement pour faute prise
à son encontre
à la fin du mois de juillet y compris la
restitution comme il se doit de ces
instruments de travail et l'abandon des
facilités qui lui étaient accordées dans
l'exercice de ses fonctions et notre
collègue jacqueline eustache brinio lui
avait notamment posé la question de ces
passeports diplomatiques
votre réponse monsieur
benalla a depuis lors été démentie par
des informations parues dans la presse
puis par les réponses apportées à notre
commission tant par le directeur du
cabinet du président de la république
que par les ministres des affaires
étrangères et de l'intérieur
vous aurez naturellement vous le savez
bien à vous expliquer sur ce point en
revanche nous n'avons pas reçu du sénat
le mandat d'interroger monsieur benalla
sur des questions importantes qui ont
trait à la politique étrangère de la
france et à la protection de nos
intérêts fondamentaux à l'étranger ce
que monsieur benalla fait et dit quand
il se rend à l'étranger au service
d'hommes d'affaires ne nous est pourtant
pas indifférent et nous pourrons à tout
le moins l'interrogé sur l'observation
par lui même des règles déontologiques
applicables à tout agent public après la
fin de ses fonctions alors qu'il nous
avait déclaré n'avoir pas repris
d'activité professionnelle en septembre
nous sommes fondés à lui demander à
quelle date
une collaboration s'est noué avec son
employeur actuel si et quand la
commission de déontologie de la fonction
publique a été saisi et si elle s'est
prononcée par ailleurs des informations
font état de la participation de
monsieur benalla à la conclusion d'un
contrat de protection de personnalités
entre monsieur kraz et un oligarque
russe alors que monsieur kraz encadrait
encore les réservistes de l'elysée et
que monsieur benalla y était chargé de
mission à la chefferie de cabinet nous
nous devons de vérifier ces informations
car si elle l'était elle témoignerait
d'un point de vulnérabilité dans la
sécurité du président de la république
qui doit à l'évidence être à l'abri de
toute influence extérieure
enfin je signale à la commission que les
investigations de l'autorité judiciaire
se sont encore étendues depuis la
dernière audition de monsieur benalla
mais cela ne change naturellement rien à
notre pratique
très soucieuse de la dépendance
réciproque des enquêtes judiciaires et
parlementaires qui doivent se combiner
dans le respect mutuel de chaque
institution
nous ne pouvons donc pas de question sur
d'éventuelles infractions pénales
commises par monsieur benalla l'objet de
notre enquête étant le fonctionnement de
l'état dans les domaines couverts par
notre mandat la justice sanctionne des
fautes individuelles
lorsqu'elles présentent un caractère
délictuel nous veillons de notre côté au
bon fonctionnement de l'état et
d'ailleurs nous sommes les seuls
constitutionnellement à être en mesure
d'effectuer ce contrôle qui ne relèvent
pas de la compétence de la justice
il se peut que nous ayons à éclairer les
mêmes faits ici usage irrégulier de
passeports diplomatiques mais nous le
ferons sous des angles différents
c'est celui de l'infraction qu'a pu
commettre le titulaire pour la justice
et c'est celui des actions mises en
oeuvre par l'état pour empêcher cet
usage irrégulier de passeport
diplomatique pour ce qui concerne le
contrôle parlementaire
chacun respecte strictement son rôle le
nôtre relève d'un droit fondamental des
représentations des représentants de la
nation de veiller au bon fonctionnement
des autorités publiques pour garantir le
bon emploi des impôts que nous votons et
prévenir les excès de pouvoir en
veillant au respect de l'état de droit
je vais rappeler à monsieur benalla des
règles qu'il connaît déjà cette audition
ouverte à la presse et au public
elle sera diffusée en direct et en vidéo
à la demande sur le site internet du
sénat
elle fera également l'objet d'un compte
rendu publié
je rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
une autre commission des lois doté des
prérogatives d'une commission denquête
serait cible de 5 ans d'emprisonnement
et de 75000 euros d'amendé
je vous invite monsieur benalla a prêté
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité levé la main droite et dit je
le jure
je le jure je vous propose monsieur
benhadda si vous le souhaitez mais vous
n'y êtes pas contraints d'introduire
cette audition par un propos liminaire à
la suite duquel nous vous poserons
certain nombre de questions il faut
remercier monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
je souhaitais avant tout en propos
liminaire remettre l'ensemble de cette
affaire dite affaire benalla dans le
contexte ce qui est le sien cette
affaire elle intervient au moment des
évènements dits du 1er mai de la place
de la contrescarpe dont on a dit un
certain nombre de choses mais surtout on
est en train de le constater maintenant
avec le temps qui passe
un certain nombre de contre-vérités un
certain nombre d'approximations à la
fois relié par la presse mais aussi par
un certain nombre de responsables
politiques
on m'a d'abord présenté comme le tabac
soeur des gentils manifestants
d'autres ont employé le mot opposants
politiques et d'autre les mangeurs de
crêpes comme ils se sont même présentés
en tronquant la réalité d'une situation
qui était pour le moins assez tendu et
on est en train de le découvrir depuis
plusieurs semaines assez confuse j'ai
dès le début lors de différentes
interventions médiatiques qui ont été
les miennes à la fois au jt de 20 heures
de tf1
également dans le journal du dimanche et
dans le journal le monde je suis revenu
sur cette situation du 1er mai où j'ai
expliqué que les personnes qui étaient
en face de moi n'étaient pas des gentils
manifestants mais des lanceurs de
bouteilles en verre sur des policiers ce
qui a été difficile à admettre pour un
certain nombre de journalistes pour un
certain nombre de responsables
politiques
mais ce qui s'est conclue être la
réalité dès lors que les vidéos sont
sorties dans les médias
après quelques semaines où on les a
quand même gardé sous le coude où on
voit ces deux personnes en train de
jeter des bouteilles en verre et
d'agresser littéralement les policiers
aujourd'hui ces deux personnes
je reviens qu'on a présenté comme des
gentils manifestants sont convoqués par
la justice pour répondre de faits de
violences sur dépositaire de l'autorité
publique
alors il ya également tout un contexte
autour de ça qui était de savoir est ce
que j'avais à agir pas agir ça c'est pas
à moi de vous le dire aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le sujet de cette audition je
t'ai bien compris ce sera à la justice
de déterminer si ce que j'ai fait le 1er
mai en contribuant à l'appréhension de
deux délinquants tout cas moi je les
qualifie comme ça deux lanceurs de
bouteilles sur des policiers
est ce que j'avais à le faire ou pas à
le faire j'ai pensé bien faire en vertu
d'un article s'appelle l'article 73 du
code de procédure pénale qui indique que
n'importe quel citoyen est autorisé à
appréhender l'auteur d'un crime ou d'un
délit flagrant et en l'occurrence le jet
d'une bouteille en verre sur des
policiers ça s'appelle un délit ce sont
des violences volontaires sur
dépositaire de l'autorité publique
à l'issue de ces pseudos révélations
d'un grand quotidien du soir il ya eu je
voulais déjà dit la dernière fois un
déferlement médiatique
un déchaînement politique un lâchage en
règle dont j'ai fait l'objet et je
continue d'ailleurs à faire l'objet
depuis six mois avec la construction
d'un personnage d'un individu comme l'a
pu l'appeler quelqu'un qui est venu
devant vous très récemment
alors que je constate et le mois de
septembre qui le tarissait pas d'éloges
me concernant mais vise apparemment là
sa vision a changé de manière assez
rapide
parce qu'en six mois on a réussi à
construire et à faire de moi un
personnage qu'on dise sulfureux
diabolique infréquentable enfin ce sont
tous les qualificatifs qui sont employés
à mon encontre et je pense de manière
très modeste avoir contribué à la
construction de ce personnage de par des
propos que j'ai pu tenir qui ont été
situés hors de leur contexte mais aussi
de par parfois mon attitude quitté qui a
peut-être été jugée décalé et je je je
conçois que j'ai pu donner une mauvaise
image de moi mais je tenais devant vous
monsieur le président à remettre dans le
contexte cette pseudo affaire benalla où
on a bien vu le cheminement la
construction médiatico-politique qui
n'avaient qu'un seul but
atteindre le président de la république
je pense que ça a marché j'espère que ça
va se terminer assez rapidement pour mon
pays et pour la réussite que je souhaite
au président de la république
en l'espace de six mois
les choses ont bien changé elles ont
évolué plutôt négativement ce qui me
concerne et je dois vous le dire et le
reconnaître derrière la carapace il ya
un homme sa femme son fils qui avait un
mois et demi au moment du déclenchement
de de cette affaire une situation
professionnelle et personnelle assez
troublée qui ont fait que j'ai commis un
certain nombre d'erreurs des erreurs que
j'ai reconnu volontiers auprès de mes
proches près de mon entourage et que je
reconnais publiquement devant vous et je
les fais également devant la justice ses
erreurs elles n'ont pu l'être de par des
rencontres de par des échanges avec
certaines personnes encore une fois
qualifié de sulfureuses et je tiens vous
le dire je rencontre qui je veux quand
je veux et dans le cadre que je veux en
fixant une limite morale que je garderai
pour moi mais je n'accepte pas le
personnage qui a été construit autour de
moi et qu'il ne reflète pas la réalité
de ce que je suis qui je suis et ce que
j'ai fait lorsque j'étais à la
présidence de la république
je venais aussi rappelé devant vous que
j'ai été recrutés sur la base de mes
compétences qui n'ont jamais été depuis
le début de vos auditions remise en
cause par qui que ce soit par qui que ce
soit
je n'ai pas débarquer à l'elysée par
effraction j'ai participé à une campagne
électorale où j'ai exercé mes
compétences avec mes qualités et mes
défauts et ont mis à recruter sur la
seule base de mes compétences et de mon
savoir faire et je demande juste un peu
d'indulgence me concernant de par le
traitement médiatique politique qui est
le mien et je pense que la justice qui
fait son travail sereinement a toute sa
place dans notre pays pour faire la
lumière sur tout ce qui m'a été reproché
depuis le début de cette affaire
j'ai entendu un certain nombre
d'approximations de mensonges et de
contrevérités dans les précédents
témoignages des gens que vous avez pu
auditionner
j'ai un immense respect pour les
fonctions qu'ils occupent et aujourd'hui
je ne vous parlerai pas de ce que je
pense des hommes dans la droite ligne de
ce que je vous ai dit la dernière fois
monsieur le président bah je suis venue
devant vous le 19 septembre
j'ai fait un certain nombre de
déclarations jaurès cohérent dans mon
propos j'ai pu entendre ici ou là qu'il
n'avait pas été suffisamment clair sur
certains points que j'avais fait de
l'enfumage tard aujourd'hui je suis
présente devant vous pour répondre à
toutes les interrogations auxquelles
vous avez jugé peut-être que j'avais été
vague tout ce que j'ai pu entendre à la
sortie de cette audition du 19 septembre
je veux juste vous confirmer mon propos
madame la sénatrice quand vous m'avez
posé la question de savoir est ce que
vous avez rendu vos passeports
diplomatiques je me souviens plus à des
termes exacts de votre question mais je
me rappelle de ma réponse le 19
septembre lorsque j'étais présent devant
vous sous serment et que j'ai répondu à
l'ensemble des questions qui m'ont été
posées
je vous ai dit ils doivent être dans mon
bureau à l'elysée et ils ont dû les
restituer puisque ma phrase est
et complète je vous réaffirme
solennellement sous serment encore une
fois que le 19 septembre mais passeport
était à l'elysée patrick strzoda vous a
affirmé que ces passeports avaient été
utilisées entre le 1er et le 7 août
ce que je ne dénie pas c'est la réalité
je les ai restituer à la demande de la
présidence de la république et du
ministère des affaires étrangères qui
m'a adressé deux courriers ainsi qu'un
email que j'ai reçu de la part du
général de farina le 30 juillet j'ai
restituer mais passeport l'aider de mon
bureau
le badge d'accès à l'elysée et j'ai
récupéré un certain nombre d'autres
affaires comme un siège auto et un
chéquier une perte de clés également et
1 alors que je désire restituer dans le
courant du mois d'août 2010 800 être
précis sur les dates pour l'instant
aucune information judiciaire est en
cours et elle viendra confirmer mon
propos et ses passeports ont été rendus
à nouveau alors que j'avais été contacté
par un membre de l'elysée un personnel
salarié de l'elysée début octobre 2018
ils m'ont été restitués comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure avec un certain
nombre d'éléments personnels un chéquier
une paire de clés dans des conditions
qui sont celles qu'elles ont été je
tiens juste à vous dire que j'ai
constaté que ces passeports et on m'a
fait savoir que ces passeports n'étaient
pas désactivé sinon je n'aurais pas
voyagé avec ses passeports et je
reconnais là une faute de ma part un
manque de discernement peut-être une
erreur sans doute gelé reconnu devant la
justice et je la reconnais devant vous
mais je ne pense pas que ça mérite les
proportions que tout ça a pris depuis le
début de cette affaire
donc je vous le réaffirme solennellement
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
le co-rapporteur mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs
je ne vous ai pas menti le 19 septembre
lorsque je vous ai dit que mes passeport
était à l'elysée et encore une fois je
fais confiance à la justice qui
travaillent dans la sphère du 1er mai
qui fait émerger un certain nombre de
vérités sur
mensonges des rumeurs des contrevérités
qui ont été développées ici ou là et
donc elle fera la même chose sur cette
affaire des passeports diplomatiques
voilà ce que je vais vous dire monsieur
le président merci monsieur benalla
j'avais donné la parole au président
jean pierre sueur co-rapporteur merci
monsieur le président monsieur benalla
je voulais d'abord vous dire que alors
que nous étions interrogés encore très
récemment philippe bas muriel jourda et
moi même avons toujours maintenu la même
position
nous sommes ici rassemblés pour trouver
la vérité pour trouver les
dysfonctionnements qui ont eu lieu pour
mettre à jour les dysfonctionnements en
chercher les causes et ensuite nous
verrons un rapport dans lequel nous
dirons ce que nous aurons à dire mais
nous respectons nous mêmes le
contradictoire c'est-à-dire que nous
auditionnons toutes les personnes que
nous avons décidé d'auditionner et pour
le moment nous en sommes là et nous
n'allons pas au delà de cet acte qui est
conforme à notre mission de
parlementaires
je voulais vous poser une première
question nous allons alterner les
questions par rapport à eux à votre
activité
quand vous étiez à l'elysée pouvez vous
confirmer véritablement que vous n'avez
été en lien avec aucune société privée
liée à des activités de sécurité de
défense ou d'autres domaines
pendant que vous exerciez vos fonctions
à l'elysée
super nanas
merci pour votre question sur le
rapporteur sur je vais réaffirmer
solennellement devant vous que je
n'avais aucun lien d'ordre professionnel
avec une société de sécurité ou de
défense comme vous me posez la question
mais pour être très clair tout le monde
sait ici je suis issu du milieu de la
sécurité la protection des personnes que
j'ai travaillé dans un certain nombre
d'entreprises auparavant et donc je me
suis créé des liens d'amitié avec un
certain nombre de personnes dans divers
domaines d'ailleurs et pas seulement la
sécurité la protection physique des
personnes et que je continue encore
aujourd'hui parce que les vrais amis
restent malgré ce déchaînement à
entretenir des liens d'amitié avec un
certain nombre de personnes mais je
répète devant vous je n'ai vu aucun lien
professionnel avec des sociétés de
sécurité et de défense lorsque j'ai
coupé mes fonctions à l'elysée le
libération a publié une déclaration de
vous entre guillemets
selon laquelle que vous auriez organisée
je cite entre guillemets deux ou trois
rendez-vous à l'elysée pendant vos
fonctions avec monsieur vincent mickeler
confirmez vous cela
et de quoi s'agissait-il je dément ces
propos et devant vous aujourd'hui pour
faire votre travail sérieusement je ne
commenterai pas les articles de presse
dans lequel il ya eu absolument tout et
son contraire et surtout beaucoup de
contre vérités qui ont été écrites
je n'ai jamais prononcé ces propos à
libération je vous donne acte de votre
réponse je voulais vous demander si vous
connaissiez monsieur iskander makhmoudov
je ne connais pas cette personne nous à
part à travers la presse je ne les ai
jamais rencontrés
e étiez vous informer de la coupole
collaboration de monsieur kraz avec
monsieur atwood off alors je
avec mathieu kraz a eu des activités
professionnelles qu'il a créé une
entreprise
j'étais au courant de ces affaires oui
c'est un ami je vais pas le cacher
devant vous aujourd'hui
tout ce que je peux vous affirmer
aujourd'hui c'est que je n'ai jamais
contribué à une quelconque négociation
conclusion est que je n'ai jamais été
intéressé au moindre contrat comme ce
crâne a pu passer avec qui que ce soit
d'ailleurs
et comment cette personne avez vous eu
des contacts avec une personne
particulièrement proches de monsieur
makhmoudov
ce qui justifierait que vous ne l'ayez
pas vu personnellement
alors pour répondre encore très
clairement et précisément je connais un
certain nombre de personnes on l'a tous
vu dans les articles de presse qui
disent parfois des vérités parfois des
mensonges mais je connais beaucoup de
gens j'en ai rencontré de par mes
anciens camarades par d'anciennes
fonctions par d'anciens emplois et donc
on est un tout petit milieu et on se
connaît absolument tout donc je connais
un certain nombre de gens soient dans
l'entourage de vincent kraz dans
l'entourage de la société si vous voulez
venir là dessus de velours ce que j'ai
travaillé pour eux et voilà je vais pas
dire le contraire mais connaître des
gens c'est ce que vous pouvez
aujourd'hui me reprocher mais je connais
beaucoup de gens oui je le connais
beaucoup de gens que s'est-il fait que
après avoir quitter vos fonctions vous
ayez été employé pendant un mois pour un
salaire qui est connu par une société
qui s'est créée pour le besoin de la
cause me semble-t-il dont l'actionnariat
est assez léger qui est dirigé par une
personne que vous devez connaître et
quelle a été votre activité dans le
cadre de cette société une activité
éphémère pour une société qui venait de
naître
monsieur le sénateur je vais répondre à
cette question même si je suis pas
obligé de vous y répondre parce que elle
c'est une activité professionnelle que
j'ai exercé à l'issue de mes activités à
l'elysée je vous avais dit quand vous
m'aviez interrogé la première fois que
j'étais à pôle emploi
j'ai essayé de quitter pôle emploi le
plus rapidement possible et j'essaye de
refaire ma vie professionnelle et
personnelle par mes propres moyens avec
certaines personnes qui me veulent du
bien et je les en remercie
et aujourd'hui je suis profondément
choquée qu'ils soient jetés en pâture
alors ce sont des entrepreneurs sérieux
qui passent des contrats et quand une
entreprise passé un contrat moi ça me
fait plaisir qui emploie des gens encore
une fois sur la base de leurs
compétences que ces gens-là retour se
retrouve avec le nom de leur société
leur prénom leur nom le passé ce qu'ils
ont fait avant et s'est jetée en pâture
comme ça c'est irresponsable
irresponsable de la part des médias qui
en fait depuis six mois
me harcèle harcèle mes proches et dont
le seul intérêt de connaître la couleur
des chaussettes que je mets le mercredi
ou le jeudi
il faut juste un moment me laisser
tranquille je travaille
j'essaie de gagner ma vie par moi même
ne pas être à la charge de la société et
cette personne c'est un ami à moi que
j'ai rencontrée je vous le dis encore
une fois c'est un petit milieu
on se connaît depuis plus de cinq ans
avec la personne que vous évoquez je
crois monsieur kraz le connaît aussi
très bien voilà il ya des concours de
circonstances qui parfois on va chercher
la petite bête mais aujourd'hui je peux
juste vous affirmer que c'est un ami qui
m'a employé dans une mission qui restera
confidentiel je suis désolé me permets
de vous demander la nature de l'activité
qui a été la vôtre
à ce titre en raison du fait que lorsque
l'on a servi
un service public grans l'elysée ce que
l'on fait après n'est pas indifférent
surtout si on a exercé des missions
liées aux missions de sécurité lorsque
l'on était à l'elysée vous savez qu'il
ya une commission de déontologie et
c'est donc je vous le demande avec
insistance qu'elle a été la nature de
votre travail durant un mois au sein de
cette société
pour des raisons de confidentialité
évidentes et du fait que ça ne concerne
pas aujourd'hui votre mission
d'information qui a des pouvoirs d'une
commission denquête je ne répondrai pas
à cette question monsieur le sénateur du
bénin et c'est nous qui décidons si nos
propres questions sont dans notre mandat
ou pas ce n'est pas à vous de le faire
je vais vous préciser les choses pour
que vous les entendiez clairement la
sanction de licenciement pour faute qui
vous a été infligée comporte un certain
nombre de dobby gassion pour vous si
cette sanction est réelle elle doit
tenait jusqu'au bout c'est la raison
pour laquelle comme vous le savez vous
deviez rendre tout ce qui était les
instruments de votre fonction et ses
attributs comme les passeports
diplomatiques d'une ligne vous ne
l'ignorez pas mais c'est aussi la raison
pour laquelle si vous le permettez
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle vous
devez respecter ayant servi au plus haut
niveau de l'état à la présidence de la
république même si vous n'étiez pas un
des principaux collaborateurs du chef de
l'état vous devez respecter l'obligation
de soumettre à la commission de
déontologie de la fonction publique
les nouvelles activités que vous pouvez
avoir tout ceci a du sens
le droit ne s'est pas simplement des
règles compose pour embêter les genres
pourquoi ces règles existent c'est pour
s'assurer d'une certaine façon que
rétrospectivement la personne qui prend
une activité dans le secteur privé après
avoir servi l'état ne peut pas se
trouver en situation de conflit
d'intérêts et c'est aussi pour vérifier
qu'à l'avenir
les fonctions que cette personne va
exercer pour le compte d'une entreprise
respectable comme vous l'avez dit par
hypothèse seront des fonctions qui ne
mettront pas en cause des informations
acquises dans l'exercice de la fonction
de service public qu'on a eu
si bien que notre commission d' enquête
s'intéresse tout à fait légitimement au
et monsieur sûr je crois est tout à fait
dans son rôle en vous posant ses
questions aux activités que vous pouvez
avoir et aux conditions dans lesquelles
vous exercer ses activités c'est à dire
que vous voyez c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de règles en france elles ne
sont pas toutes inutile et dépourvue de
sens c'est là beaucoup de sens en
réalité donc je reformule la question de
jean-pierre sueur différemment avant de
prendre une activité dans une entreprise
avez-vous petit 1 saisi la commission de
déontologie et petit petit b petit 2
avez vous informé la présidence de la
république que vous repreniez comme
c'est nécessaire pour vous même et pour
votre famille
une activité professionnelle et la
nature de cette activité professionnelle
ça c'est extrêmement important c'est le
respect des dispositions du décret du 27
janvier 2017
je vous remercie pour votre intervention
monsieur le président en sueur en effet
vous avez raison c'est très important
et d'ailleurs c'est tellement important
que j'ai reçu le courrier de monsieur
strzoda m'indiquant que j'avais à saisir
la commission de déontologie de la
fonction publique deux jours avant qu'il
soit auditionné par vos soins à sa
dernière audition
c'est tellement important qu'il serait
intéressant aussi de savoir combien de
personnes quittant l'elysée depuis
plusieurs mandats il faudrait
s'intéresser aux derniers mandats ont
saisi cette commission de déontologie
pour avoir des activités
professionnelles et pour créer leur
entreprise
ça je pense que c'est un travail qui
pourrait être assez intéressant
et pourquoi on me demande à moi trois
jours avant de venir dans une commission
denquête de saisir cette confiance qui
m'avait ce dont je n'avais pas été
informé mais qui était mentionné dans
mon contrat de travail c'est tout à fait
exact
je ne l'ait pas fait c'est une erreur de
ma part je la reconnais mais il serait
intéressant de s'intéresser savoir
combien de personnes en sortant de
l'elysée saisissent la commission de
déontologie de la fonction publique mais
on le suivait n'a là vous n'avez pas
tout faux billets administrative arriver
vous savez bien qu'il faut respecter d
un certain nombre de règles et vous
venez de rappeler que c'était dans votre
contrat de travail
c'est pas très compliqué à faire je
pense que ça a été la situation à
l'issue de mes fonctions à l'elysée a
été un peu compliqué
je n'ai pas été orientés vers cette
commission de déontologie
j'aurais dû en effet le 1er août
reprendre mon contrat de travail et
relire chaque paraphe et voir que je
devais saisir cette commission de
déontologie je ne l'ait pas fait c'est
en effet c'est une erreur de ma part
mais j'avais d'autres priorités comme
celle de mettre à l'abri et ma femme et
mon fils de retrouver un appartement un
travail
ces deux situations en fait un tout
petit peu compliqué ce qui se passe chez
b d'alan nous ne sommes pas là pour vous
faire la morale mais je pourrais essayer
d'avoir des informations qui nous
permettent d'établir la vérité mais
c'est certain que quand on respecte les
règles on est mieux protégé alors je
voudrais savoir si depuis lors vous avez
effectivement saisi la commission de
déontologie
non je n'ai pas saisi la commission de
déontologie et mon avocate est en train
de s'en occuper
je vous remercie madame ma jourda merci
monsieur le président j'ai quelques
questions à monsieur benalla sur le port
d'armes
le préfet de police de paris vous a
délivré le 13 octobre 2017
outre un permis de port d'armes une
autorisation d'acquisition et de
détention d'une arme de catégorie b
uniquement valable pour la durée de vos
fonctions à la présidence de la
république
selon les informations nous avons à vous
bénéficiez déjà depuis le mois de
novembre 2016 d'une autorisation de
détention d'armes de cette même
catégorie au motif que vous pratiquez le
tir sportif
avez-vous acquis
une nouvelle arme au titre de
l'autorisation d'acquisition et
détention délivré par le préfet de
police le 13 octobre 2017
et si oui cette arme at elle été acquise
par vous même à titre privé ou par
l'elysée alors je répondrais de manière
très succincte parce qu'il ya une
information judiciaire en cours là
dessus sur l'histoire des armes du
fameux selphy je peux juste vous dire
que larmes qui a été acquise dans le
cadre de cette autorisation l'a été par
moi-même dans la mesure où
l'autorisation dont vous bénéficiez
était liée à vos fonctions à l'elysée
avait vous restituer cette arme
postérieurement cette arme ont été ses
armes pendant toutes les armes que je
détenais de manière légale ont été
saisis par la justice dans le cadre de
l'information judiciaire qui est en
cours
merci de cette réponse mesdames jourda
d'autres questions allez-y calaisis
allez-y pas d'aujourd'hui sur sur les
soupes la question du sahara dont
monsieur urbain
je crois que madame jourdain voulait
poser une question je vous redonne la
parole après une question cette facile
monsieur menace sur le téléphone
théorème qui permettent aux
collaborateurs situés au plus haut
niveau de l'état de passer des
communications chiffrées
selon les informations qui nous ont été
données par monsieur strzoda directeur
de cabinet du président de la république
la présidence dispose de trente combiné
vous même vous disposiez dans ses
combinés alors à quelle fin disposez
vous d'un téléphone théorème dans le
cadre de vos fonctions à l'elysée
à quelles fins l'utilisiez vous pour
préparer des déplacements pour
communiquer avec le président kabila
alors pour répondre à cette question le
théorème en effet est un outil qui est
mis à disposition d'un certain nombre de
collaborateurs du président de la
république et d'autres administrations
qui permet d'avoir un certain nombre de
conversations téléphoniques de manière
sécurisée
quand j'étais collaborateurs du
président de la république dans les
fonctions qui étaient les miennes j'ai
traité excusez moi très soucieux des
procédures
et de la sécurité des communications je
pouvais avoir il m'a été attribué un
théorème dans le cadre des missions que
je vous ai exposé lors de la première
audition juste certains n'ont pas jugé
utile d'en avoir un préférant passer par
des messagerie crypté bien connu
télégramme ou whatsapp moi j'ai respecté
les procédures
c'est à dire que lorsqu'on a des
discussions à voir avec des prêts faits
avec les autorités se veulent la police
la gendarmerie ou d'autres personnes qui
ont leurs fonctions à l'elysée
j'utilisais le théorème ont la clé un
outil qui a été achetée est plutôt
qu'ils soient dans un carton je
l'utilisais et monsieur benalla ça veut
dire que le chef de cabinet du président
de la république ne jugeait pas utile
pour ses propres communications avec les
mêmes correspondante d'utiliser un tel
appareil et c'est donc vous qui à la
chefferie de cabinet l'utilisez-vous sol
mais de votre propre initiative en
quelque sorte vous vous avez pensé que
c'était utile alors que d'autres
pensaient que c'était inutile
je pense que vous avez parfaitement
résumé la situation de monsieur le
président je vous remercie monsieur
sueur au pardon maintenant cette fois
madame jourda qui tout à l'heure hésité
à engager à nouveau questionnaire
questionnement demande a continué sur le
même sujet oui j'aurais bien voulu
doit-on saisir de vos propos monsieur
vénéra que ce téléphone vous l'aviez
demandé et qui nous aide qui ne vous
avait pas été attribués d'office
alors en fait nous avons des postes
fixes sécurisé dans chacun de nos
bureaux à la chefferie de cabinet les
pokes les postes mobiles ne sont pas
attribuées de manière automatique
alors même que nous les fonctions qui
sont les nôtres de par l'habilitation
etc emporte le fait qu'on peut demander
ce type de mobile après c'est en
fonction de l'usagé qu'on veut en faire
et du respect moi j'ai un respect des
procédures de sécurité et je les ai
utilisés aux fins qui pour lequel il est
effet serre téléphoner dans des
conditions de sécurité
axione d'autres ne l'ont pas jugé utile
s'est alors posé la question
oui mais vous n'avez pas tout à fait
répondu à ma question l'aviez vous
demandez où vous at il été attribuée
d'office
alors il m'a été attribué
vous confirmez que ce téléphone n'a pas
été restitué lors de votre licenciement
et le cas échéant la restitution vous at
elle été réclamés après votre
licenciement à quel moment et qu'elle
diligence avez-vous accompli pour que ce
cette restitution ait lieu pour inscrire
ma réponse dans le contexte général que
je vous ai exposé tout alors monsieur le
président bah la situation après le 1er
août était un peu confuse me concernant
j'ai déménagé en six mois plus de quatre
fois avec un certain nombre d'affaires
dans des cartons c'est une situation
compliquée je vais pas m'étaler
là-dessus mais ce téléphone ne m'a
jamais été redemandé et je n'avais pas
connaissance
jusqu'au mois de décembre que je l'avais
encore en ma possession c'est à dire que
le dernier déménagement que j'ai fait le
20 novembre 2018 pour être tout à fait
précis avec vous j'ai ouvert des cartons
et lorsqu'on a commencé à me demander la
restitution d'un certain nombre d'effets
qui n'avait pas été rendue à l'elysée
la carte professionnelle le pin's et un
certain nombre d'autres documents et il
n'était pas mentionné le théorème est
donc j'ai demandé fait avec ma femme un
inventaire complet des affaires qui
n'était pas encore déballés on à
déballer les cartons et on est tombé sur
le théorème est donc j'ai appelé mon
avocate qui a pris effet les démarches
auprès de monsieur strzoda pour savoir
comment on pouvait restituer ce
téléphone voilà et depuis il a été
restitué à l'elysée nomme jourda une
dernière question et je redonne la
parole à jean pierre sueur toujours sur
ce téléphone quel usage j'avoue fait de
cet outil depuis votre licenciement
comme je vous ai dit il ya eu aucun
usage de ce téléphone ce que je n'avais
pas connaissance pendant les six mois
qui se sont écoulés avant que je fasse
un inventaire complet des affaires qui
étaient encore dans des cartons
que je l'avais encore en ma possession
voilà donc il n'a jamais été utilisé
depuis le mois de juillet 2018 je vous
remercie jean pierre sueur sur ce
téléphone
l'elysée nous a affirmé vous avoir
demandé de le restituer le 4 octobre ce
qui est un peu loin par rapport jeu la
date de votre départ
mais vous ne l'avez pas restitué le 4
octobre bien qu'on voulait demander
alors contrairement à ce que vous
affirmez je sais pas qui a dit ça sur la
base de quoi il se met ce téléphone ne
m'a jamais été réclamée le 4 octobre
ils ont découvert apparemment lorsque
mon avocate a appelé pour leur dire
qu'on en était en possession que je
l'avais encore mais ça n'a jamais été
demandée par l'elysée le 4 octobre
en réalité le téléphone a été désactivé
le 4 octobre
ce tueur ce qui est étrange c'est une
remarque c'est que il est était que
l'élysée donc alors que vous avez quitté
l'elysée le 31 juillet ne se feront du
compte de cette affaire que le 4 octobre
et ce en étant rendu compte si je
comprends ce que vous dites n'est pas
réagi auprès de vous pour vous demander
de le restituer c'est exactement ce que
vous dites je ne sais pas répondre à
votre question je pense que j'appelle le
placer pour les rapports ou port d'armes
permettez moi une question à laquelle
peut-être vous ne répondrai pas mais il
peut peut être être utile pour vous de
répondre
il ya une perquisition vous en souvenez
cette perquisition n'a donné lieu à
aucune instance judiciaire
elle n'est pas couvert par la justice
les conditions dans lesquelles la
perquisition a eu lieu
il a été question d'une armoire est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire plus sur
son contenu ou est-ce que vous ne pouvez
pas la perquisition elle s'est fait sur
instruction bien suivi un magistrat donc
par la justice et donc je ne rentrerai
pas dans des réponses
concerne l'information judiciaire et
l'instruction aussi la justice est des
questions à me poser là dessus elle me
les posera mais tout s'est fait dans un
cadre légal et une vraie perquisition à
mon domicile avec des vrais policiers
j'en suis le premier témoin tout a été
fait conformément à la loi
voilà bien bien merci jeudi dans sur
huit autres alors qu'ils ont par rapport
à eux au passeport
on a constaté que vous aviez une
certaine appétence pour les passeports
mais bon après tout chacun a ses
marottes
mais ce qui est quand même un peu
étrange c'est que s'agissant du
passeport diplomatique dont vous avez
demandé le renouvellement
premièrement vous avez demandé sur vous
de renouvellement au moment où après une
sanction qui vous était arrivé qui a été
donc terminée vous avez été déchargé de
la mission de l'organisation des voyages
du président de la république
donc il peut sembler étrange quand vous
que vous demandiez un passeport
diplomatique au moment où n'avez vous
n'avez plus la mission qui justifierait
l'attribution le renouvellement du
passeport diplomatique
première question pourquoi avez vous
demandé ce passeport diplomatique alors
que vous n'aviez plus la fonction qui
aurait justifié que vous le demandiez
deuxièmement vous n'êtes pas passés par
le service du protocole de l'elysée
pourquoi puisque c'est la voie normale
vous avez obtenu ce passeport ce
renouvellement très rapidement auprès du
ministère des affaires étrangères qui en
a d'ailleurs informé monsieur le drian
nous l'a dit le service du protocole de
l'elysée qui après d'après nos
informations n'a pas réagi d'aucune
sorte
d'après nos informations donc je vous
pose ces questions pourquoi avez vous
demandé le renouvellement à cette époque
là pourquoi et prenait 2 vous pas passer
par le service du protocole alors
je suis désolé monsieur le sénateur mais
les conditions d'attribution de
détention et d'obtention
c'est que de restitution de ces
passeports concerne l'information
judiciaire en cours et j'aurai des
questions donc de deux juges
d'instruction qui sont saisis là dessus
donc je ne répondrai pas à ces questions
devant votre commission j'en suis désolé
monsieur bédard vous êtes obligé de
répondre à ces questions devant notre
commission elle concerne le
fonctionnement de l'état et non pas des
fautes que vous auriez pu commettre
et elles ne sont donc pas reliés à cette
information judiciaire sauf en avoir une
compréhension particulièrement extensif
vous précise d'ailleurs mais je l' ai
déjà dit plusieurs fois que nos missions
sont complémentaires ne pouvons nous
intéresser aux mêmes faits mais pas pour
le même objet la justice veut
s'intéresser à l'utilisation vous faites
un passeport diplomatique s'il ya une
infraction dans cette utilisation par
vous même
nous ne nous intéressons pas du tout ça
en revanche il est très important pour
nous de su mais notre mission
constitutionnelle sans en rien limiter
les capacités d'action de la justice nos
missions sont complémentaires et pas
concurrentes sur ce qui concerne les
procédures administratives qui ont eu
lieu nous voulons savoir comment cette
attribution a eu lieu
elle n'est pas poursuivie en tant que
tel comme une infraction non pas
l'attribution de ce passeport
diplomatique alors que la justice vous
pose des questions là-dessus
nous sommes tout à fait d'accord pour
qu'elle le fasse mais nous vous posons
aussi des questions là dessus et vous
êtes obligés d'y répondre
j'ai bien entendu votre propos monsieur
présidentielle mais je suis désolé je
vous monsieur président bart excusez moi
j'ai vu je ne pourrais pas répondre à
cette question parce que contrairement à
ce que vous affirmez la justice
s'intéresse aux conditions de délivrance
et d'obtention de l'ensemble des
passeports et pas seulement les
passeports diplomatiques dans le cadre
d'une information judiciaire qui est
ouverte sur cinq
motif d'infraction et pas seulement
lusage j'ai été mis en examen en effet
simplement sur l' usage abusive d'un
document de notre fonction mais je suis
placé comme témoin assisté sur quatre
chefs d'inculpation
ce n'est pas tant un statut que
l'ouverture d'une information sur ces
cinq chefs d'inculpation qui m'empêche
de répondre à cette question
g le rappeler nous c'est cinq chefs
d'informations s'il vous plaît je pense
qu'ils ont été rendus publics par le
parquet monsieur le président bah oui
mais monsieur monsieur vénale à notre
question ne porte pas sur l' usage d'un
passeport il ne porte pas sur une autre
question ne porte pas sur les passeports
de service par rapport à laquelle vous
êtes témoin assisté il porte sur les
conditions d'obtention du renouvellement
d'un passeport alors que vous êtes dans
une institution l'elysée et nous voulons
mener c'est pas parce que la justice
fait son travail que nous ne devons pas
faire le nôtre c'est très clair et c'est
une question absolument essentiel pour
aujourd'hui et pour demain
ou bien on pense que les commissions
d'enquêté parlementaires ne doivent pas
exercer leurs missions
constitutionnelles qui est de contrôler
le gouvernement est d'évaluer les
politiques publiques ce qui se passe à
l'elysée notamment en matière de
sécurité relève de la politique publique
à partir du moment où vous les lisez non
pas l'elysée vous au sein de l'elysée
demandé et obtenu un tel passeport
diplomatique
nous sommes en droit de vous interroger
pour la sur la question de savoir
pourquoi cela a été demandé
alors que vous n'aviez plus de titres à
disposer d'un passeport diplomatique et
pourquoi vous avez contours a été
contournée je ne dis même pas vous a été
contourné le service du protocole de
l'elysée et voilà la question est très
simple subhanallah alors je vais
réitérer mon propos une troisième fois
la justice étant saisi des faits
concernant les passeports au sens large
et les passeports de service et les
passeports diplomatiques
s'intéressant également aux conditions
d'obtention de ces passeports et non pas
simplement conditions d'utilisation une
information judiciaire étant ouverte et
étant très respectueux des institutions
je répondrai aux questions des
magistrats instructeurs monsieur b nana
permettez moi de vous dire que ce n'est
pas être très respectueux des
institutions que de refuser de répondre
aux questions qui vous sont posées par
une commission d' enquête parlementaire
vous avez une conception singulière de
ce que c'est que le respect des
institutions je dois vous dire que le
respect des institutions
c'est aussi savoir que l'autorité
judiciaire n'a pas le droit de porter
d'appréciation sur une décision
administrative et par conséquent c'est
bien à nous de le faire chacun a son
rôle complémentaire la justice vérifiera
si vous avez ou non commis des
infractions
à ce titre elle peut tout à fait
chercher des informations dans tel ou
tel domaine de l'action administrative
mais ne peut porter d'appréciation sur
la régularité d'une décision
administrative ce qui est une évidence
pour tout le monde et vous qui avez fait
des études de droit vous devriez le
savoir aussi je vois votre obstination à
ne pas répondre
aux questions de la commission denquête
et je n'en comprends pas la raison je
tenais à vous lui direz je rends la
parole à monsieur suaire juste monsieur
bah pour essieu benalla si vous voulez
je n'ai absolument rien à cacher quant à
l'obtention et l'utilisation de ces
passeports et j'en serais aujourd'hui le
premier ravi de pouvoir vous expliquer
comment j'ai pu les obtenir
et comment ils m'ont été délivré et
comment je les ai utilisés
sauf que dès lors qu'il ya une suspicion
que les conditions de délivrance ont
donné lieu à une infraction pénale
on n'est plus dans un cadre
administratif mais dans un cadre
judiciaire et aujourd'hui la justice
s'intéresse à savoir comment j'ai obtenu
ces passeports
donc je vous réitère pour la quatrième
fois que je ne pourrais pas répondre à
cette question qui n'est pas une
question d'ordre administratives mais
d'ordre judiciaire
monsieur nana la justice
s'intéresse-t-elle vraiment aux
conditions dans lesquelles vous avez
obtenu le renouvellement de votre
passeport diplomatique au mois de juin
dernier
ce n'est pas ce que j'ai entendu le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république à utiliser l'article 40 du
pote du code de procédure pénale non pas
pour l'attribution de ces passeports
diplomatiques mais pour la note à
en-tête du chef de cabinet du président
de la république par laquelle a été
demandé le renouvellement de votre
passeport de service qui n'a rien à voir
avec le renouvellement de votre
passeport diplomatique au mois de juin
dernier mais nous en resterons là je
vous donne acte de votre refus de
répondre mais je tiens à vous dire que
votre interprétation est erroné et que
d'ailleurs vous n'avez pas à opposer à
une commission d' enquête parlementaire
votre propre interprétation par rapport
à celle que nous faisons car c'est notre
rôle d'interpréter notre mandat est de
définir le champ des questions que nous
avons à vous poser et auxquelles vous
pourriez répondre j'ai précisé en
commençant cette audition à quel point
nous sommes de ce point de vue très
attentif à faire en sorte que la
séparation des pouvoirs soient respectés
et la conception que vous en affirmé est
de mon point de vue comme de celui des
rapporteurs abusive alors j'ai bien
entendu encore une fois votre remarque
monsieur le président bas
je suis assez inquiet de voir qu'une
première fois devant votre commission le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république a évoqué que j'allais être
convoqué dans les toutes prochaines
heures
ce qui pose quand même des questions sur
l'indépendance des institutions et
aujourd'hui vous êtes en train de
m'expliquer que vous n'avez pas
connaissance que dans le dossier la
justice s'intéresse à la condition
d'obtention et de délivrance de ces
passeports
je ne sais pas si vous avez eu accès au
dossier judiciaire vous même mais ça me
pose question quand même monsieur
monsieur v ne la suivait n'a là je me
fonde sur les chiffres sur les chefs
d'un crédit nation et sur les
déclarations du parquet du même monsieur
le président sur wii je voulais vous
dire monsieur benalla qu' il n'y a pas
pas il n'y a pas eu moins de quatre
ministres et une certaine époque nous
ont rappelé qu'il était tout à fait
nécessaire que nous respections nos
prérogatives
donc nous ne pouvons qu insisté sur la
grande nécessité de respecter
l'indépendance de la justice comme la
justice se doit de respecter notre
indépendance mais surtout comme le
pouvoir exécutif se doit de respecter
l'indépendance du pouvoir législatif
mais monsieur benalla vous ne dîtes que
pour ces raisons liées à la justice vous
ne pouvez pas parler des passeports mais
vous voyez qu'il y a une petite
contradiction car dans votre déclaration
préalable
vous avez commencé par nous parler de
passeport alors attendez ce n'est pas
fini ma question
donc vous avez commencé par nous dire
que suite à la question de madame
eustache brinio notre collègue
vous avez apporté une réponse vous avez
apporté la réponse suivante que les
passeports quand vous avez quitté
l'elysée était resté dans votre bureau
tout à l'heure vous avez dit les
passeports sont restés à l'elysée c'est
une nuance qui a de l'importance
est-ce que vous pouvez nous confirmer
que les passeports sont restés dans
votre bureau à l'elysée alors je vous
êtes très précis monsieur ensuite très
précis je vais d'abord rebondir sur le
fait que je n'ai pas évoqué alors autre
question portait sur les passeports
je n'ai pas excusez moi je n'ai pas
répondu à cette question parce qu'elle
s'inscrivait dans le cadre d'une
information judiciaire qui est ouverte
et que dans mon propos liminaire j'ai
évoqué ces passeports
je suis juste resté cohérent et des
propos qui ont été publics à travers un
certain nombre de communiqués à deux
mois et un de mon avocate
donc je n'avais pas vous dire je ne vais
pas je vous répète simplement les propos
qui ont été derrière il ya une quinzaine
de jours et ces propos qui sont
publiques et que vous pouvez trouver
dans la presse donc je sais pas révélé
de secret et je n'étais pas encore mis
en examen ni placé sous le statut de
témoin assisté il ya quinze jours pour
les passeports
je vais vous accordez en effet sur les
déclarations et pour être encore plus
précis que vous l'êtes
lorsque j'ai répondu à madame la
sénatrice et dernière fois sur les
passeports j'ai dit je pense je pense et
penser c'est une nuance qui a une
extrême importance que mes passeports
sont dans mon bureau à l'élysée et
qu'ils ont dû être restituée pensée
n'est pas affirmé mais tout ce que je
peux vous affirmer je les fais encore
une fois sous serment aujourd'hui c'est
que mes passeport était à l'elysée le 19
septembre
voilà monsieur le président sion il y a
eu ensuite une perquisition c'est la
dernière question de notre corps à
porter car nous avons beaucoup de
collègues qui demandent également la
parole donc il y a eu une perquisition
et ensuite on vous a rendu les
passeports
est ce que vous êtes plus vous pouvez
être plus précis quelle personne vous a
rendu les passeports au coin d'une rue
avez-vous dit c'est comme ça que ça
s'est passé
encore une fois une information
judiciaire qui est ouverte et la justice
exposera dans des conditions claires la
manière dont les passeports ont été
rendues puis ensuite restituée comment
et par qui la remportera madame jourdain
juste une question oui et après nous
laisserons la parole à nos collègues de
la commission des lois
s'agissant des passeports de service
monsieur strzoda nous expliquer que vous
bénéficiez de deux passeports de service
l'un qui avait été délivré en 2016
lorsque vous travaillez à la délégation
interministérielle aux outre-mer et
l'autre délivré le 28 juin 2018 dans le
cadre de vos fonctions à l'elysée
alors si vous nous confirmer ces
informations c'est à dire la détention
de ses deux passeports pouvait ou ne
pouvez vous nous expliquer quel en était
l'utilité dans la mesure où vous
disposez déjà de deux passeports
diplomatiques
je suis encore désolé madame la
sénatrice je ne pourrais pas répondre à
cette question qui porte sur une
information judiciaire qui est en cours
vous avez une conception extrêmement
large de l'information monsieur bénard
mais je n'ai pas le pouvoir de vous
faire parler si vous ne souhaitez pas je
ne peux que me rallier aux explications
longues qui a tant donné par le
président bas et déploré que vous ne
souhaitiez pas répondre à la mission
d'information juste chaudraies madame la
la cour rapporte pénale à vous dire que
j'ai répondu de la manière la plus
précise complète et cohérente depuis le
début de vos auditions à l'ensemble de
vos questions je ne décide pas d'être
mis en examen ou placé sous le statut de
témoin assisté ou qu'une information
judiciaire soit ouverte ou non je
respecte juste le cadre de ce qui m'a
été conseillé par mon avocate de ne pas
faire d'autant incrimination ce que dès
lors que vous êtes mis en cause par la
justice et le statut porte peu seul une
mise en examen ou de témoin assisté
toutes les déclarations que je peux
faire devant vous sous serment peuvent
être retenues contre moi par la justice
ultérieurement donc
excusez moi juste de respecter des
principes qui me sont garantis par la
constitution
ce bénin là je suis d'accord avec vous
sur ce point
le risque de l'auto incrimination nous
ne voulons pas nous mêmes que vous
puissiez l'an courir mais quand il
s'agit du fonctionnement de
l'administration ce n'est pas des actes
que vous avez commis que nous vous
demandons de parler mais des actes qui
ont été accomplis par des services de
l'administration vous voyez vous sentez
bien la différence entre les deux et il
faut que vous cessiez de considérer que
les deux enquêtes parlementaires et
judiciaires devraient s'exclure l'une et
l'autre elle se complète ne sont pas en
concurrence
nous sommes ici très heureux que la
justice fasse son travail
elle fait un travail que nous ne
pourrions pas faire mais de la même
façon nous en faisons un qu'elle ne
pourrait pas faire non plus c'est pour
ça de notre république
les dispositifs de contrôle sont
multiples à chacun son rôle
voilà men ou d'asthme s'il vous plaît
nous allons nous en tenir là parce que
mes collègues vont vous reposer des
questions vous aurez l'occasion de
nouveau de vous exprimer juste monsieur
prennent alors allez juste excusez moi
simplement vous me posez des questions
sur l'administration journée questions
qui m'ont été posées m'ont été posées à
moi directement concernant des actes que
j'aurai accompli ou de l'usaj que
j'aurais pu avoir ou l'utilité que
j'aurais pu avoir à me faire délivrer
ces passeports
c'est la question c'est la nature même
de la question qui m'a été poussés parce
que là ça touche à votre à votre
fonction à l'elysée la question était
pourquoi auriez vous eu encore besoin
d'un nouveau passeport diplomatique au
moins de juin
alors qu'on nous a dit vous ne l'avez
pas démente et que vous étiez décharger
de votre participation à l'organisation
des déplacements du chef de l'état à
l'étranger
c'est juste ça et c'est vrai que je dis
que vous auriez normalement dû être en
mesure de répondre à cette question
simple sans vous exposer au risque
d'auto incrimination
je suis en situation de pouvoir déduire
de votre non réponse que la question
vous gêne non pas du tout absolument pas
j'avais des questions qui me gênait je
vous l'aurais dit depuis longtemps
j'aurai pas répondu de manière aussi
claire est longue et précise que je les
fais depuis 19 septembre
ce que je peux vous dire si ça votre
question concerne le fonctionnement de
l'administration
ces passeports ont été délivrés
normalement et c'est en cas aucun moment
une objection quelconque interviennent
depuis que j'ai quitté mes fonctions
ou alors que j'étais en fonction c'est
tout ce que je peux vous dire
aujourd'hui monsieur le président bas et
si l'administration avait jugé anormale
la délivrance des passeports
elle l'aurait souligné elle l'aurait
soulever pour les passeports de service
ils ont été annulés et pour les
passeports diplomatiques je constate que
non et le service du protocole de
l'elysée informé par le quai d'orsay du
renouvellement de ce passeport
diplomatique ne nous a fait aucune
observation
non je vous remercie monsieur watts blé
monsieur bellona
ma question est la suivante entre le 1er
août date à laquelle monsieur vous êtes
licencié le 3 et le 31 décembre 2018
vous avez d'après monsieur strzoda
directeur du cabinet du président la
république utiliser deux passeports
diplomatiques une vingtaine de fois lors
de ses déplacements
avez vous comme vous l'avait indiqué
dans la côté de presse toujours prévenu
la plus haute autorité française
monsieur ben alla je suis même sûr sept
ans mais je ne commenterai pas les
articles de presse je commenterai mes
propres déclarations en l'occurrence un
communiqué qui a été le mien j'ai avisé
des personnes de l'ensemble de mes
déplacements à l'étranger
par courtoisie républicaine je n'ai pas
saisi la commission de déontologie de la
fonction publique mais j'ai expliqué un
peu ce que je faisais depuis que j'ai
quitté mes fonctions
ma question était plus précise la plus
haute autorité française
alors ce n'est pas une personne c'est
une institution dont je parle en mais
ces bd là qui sont les personnes que
vous avez informé donc des gens qui
travaillaient à la plus haute autorité
française c'est-à-dire des membres de la
présidence de la république et qu'elle
fonctionne occupe-t-elle je ne souhaite
pas évoquer leurs fonctions aujourd'hui
ni leur nom ni leur prénom je suis
désolé monsieur sur à quelle date
avez-vous prévenu les personnes en
question de l'elysée de votre
déplacement au tchad alors je suis
désolé mais je ne répondrai pas à cette
question je le co rapporteur sur qui
concerne des déplacements postérieure à
mes fonctions à l'elysée
ça nous permet d'accélérer notre
audition présidence si vous le permettez
celle ci après ce qui se passe après a
un rapport avec ce qui s'est passé avant
dans les déplacements que vous avez fait
récemment est tout à fait le droit de
vous déplacer
yat il était question de la sphère
d'activité dont vous étiez chargé à
l'elysée y at il une connexion entre la
sphère d'activité dont vous étiez chargé
à des 10es est l'objet de ses
déplacements au n'y at il aucun rapport
ni aucun rapport et lorsque vous avez
été reçu par des chefs d'état est-ce que
vous avez été reçu par rapport à des
missions dont vous pourriez nous parler
ou pas ou par rapport
à ce qu étaient vos anciennes fonctions
a aucune
j'ai été reçu en tant que alexandre
benalla et je suis désolé mais je n'ai
pas pu changer de prénom
je pense que l'on est ni de nom et que
malheureusement
contre mon gré il a acquis une notoriété
qui est parti jusqu'en afrique ait
jamais été reçue pour remplir aucune
mission pour mon ancien employeur ni
même pour avoir des fonctions ou des
emplois ou des discussions en rapport
avec mes anciennes fonctions c'était des
déplacements à titre privé j'ai
rencontré un certain nombre de personnes
à titre privé et je les ai rencontrés
avec mon prénom est mon nom qui
s'appelle alexandre benalla voilà je
suis désolé de ça mais c'est le cadre de
ses déplacements quotidiens
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
benalla de bourg soit propre peau
liminaire il est exact effectivement des
manifestations largement postérieures au
1er mai ont montré des violences lors
des manifestations telles que j'en fais
y est hein mais c'est sur les passeports
toujours voudrais vous interroger sur la
pratique courante
est-ce que selon vous ces pratiques
courantes effectivement d'utiliser des
passeport diplomatique ou de service
jusqu'à expiration
or parce qu'ils ont quitté eux les
fonctions si c'était interdit
vous vous l'at on dit a été dit puisque
aujourd'hui votre ancien employeur a
porté plainte pour ce motif
c'est la première question en étiez vous
informer et quelle est la pratique
courante selon vous est-ce que vous
soyez le seul est poursuivi pour avoir
violé cette interdiction
la deuxième question c'est vous
dit avoir informé la présidence quand
vous refusez donner les noms sauf si
vous étiez en missions officielles ou
parallèles pour le la dgs ou que sais je
vois pas en quoi vous pouvez ne pas dire
à la commission denquête qui vous avait
informé mais nous avons entendu le
ministre de l'intérieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères le directeur de
cabinet nous dire qu'ils ignoraient tout
de vos déplacements à l'étranger pendant
quatre mois ne l'avoir découvert que par
le canard enchaîné alors est ce que ça
vous paraît vraisemblable vous même bon
marianne vous cite en disant que vous
aurais dit comme ça ils sauront suis un
bon arrêt ce que ça vaut mais est-ce que
très honnêtement il pouvait l'ignorer
de la même façon est ce qui vous paraît
vraisemblable
que l'ambassadeur de france à djamena
n'est pas informée paris de ce que vous
vous soyez déplacés au tchad vous
paraît-il vraisemblable que mills
affaires étrangères nous disent avoir
tout appris
le 26 sachant que le président de
république a été là le 22 décembre à
paris enfin dernière question d'autres
oliviera djamena n'djamena par ménage et
par ailleurs troisième question vous
disiez vous même avoir gêné dans vos
fonctions et est là n'avez-vous pas le
sentiment d'avoir gêné certains nous
disent que vous n'existez plus à
l'élysée que vous êtes mort d'autres
disent au contraire que vous auriez pu
renseigner même utilement le président
sur l'emploi des forces de l'ordre
pendant les manifestations ou encore sur
la réalité au tchad y compris sur le
rôle des russes pourquoi pas au tchad et
qui était nécessaire pour le président
de le savoir et qui n'auraient pas par
les voies officielles
et est ce que vous n'avez pas à ce
moment-là irrité
il irrite est est ce que ce serait pas à
l'origine
je veux dire de la plainte et des ennuis
qui vous sont faits et des informations
qui nous sont donnés merci 20 ans
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup chers collègues alors une
pile poil vous tenez votre temps je suis
admiratif et donc basculé dans la
pouvez-vous répondre à l'ensemble de ces
questions alors sur l'information que je
ne pouvais pas utiliser ces passeports
elle ne m'a pas été fournies par aucun
moyen que ce soit ce que je vous ai dit
en propos liminaire et je leur confirme
encore devant vous ils m'ont été rendue
début octobre et ils étaient utilisables
c'est à dire sans aucune mention dessus
pas accompagnée d'un courrier qui
m'empêchait de les utiliser
et c'est une connerie de ma part de les
avoir utilisés au vu de la polémique qui
est qui est sorti après ils sont été
rendu par qui je vous ai déjà dit que je
ne répondrai pas à cette question de sur
le grand tube et dallas alors c'est la
présidence de la république qui nous a
menti vous en tirer je pense que l'
enquête judiciaire va déterminer la
vérité avec les moyens qui sont les
siens
mais je vous affirme sans porter aucune
accusation que j'ai rendu mes passeport
à la fin août et qu'ils ont été
restitués en début octobre
en ce qui concerne la pratique courante
j'ai entendu à l'occasion de vos
auditions que une inspection générale
avait été diligentée par le ministère de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères et
qui s'étaient aperçus qu'un certain
nombre de passeports diplomatiques alors
même que les personnes ne cesser leurs
fonctions
continuez en tout cas si ce n'est pas de
les utiliser à les conserver
je suis incapable de vous dire si des
gens se servent de leur passeport après
je vous répète juste le propos qui a été
celui d'une des personnes que vous avez
auditionné
c'est à dire que des gens qui tenant
plusieurs administrations d'ailleurs et
qui dispose de passeports diplomatiques
quittent leurs fonctions et ne restitue
pas les passeports en question est-ce
qu'ils voyagent avec je suis incapable
de vous y répondre moi en tout cas j'ai
avouez de la manière la plus simple
possible que j'avais voyagé avec ses
passeports et j'en assumerai les
responsabilités ma responsabilité devant
la justice qui aujourd'hui me le
reproche
et voilà c'est tout ce que je peux vous
dire là dessus sur les autres sur les
autres questions est-ce que vous pouvez
peut-être là j'ai pas noté la troisième
question qui était la vôtre monsieur
grosdidier ce que le miz affaires
étrangères pouvaient ignorer
je veux dire déplacement le ministre
d'intérieur est ce que l'ambassadeur de
france pouvait oublier de signer les à
paris que vous étiez à la djamena de 12
alors que le président il y aller le 22
et est il vraisemblable que le musée
affaires étrangères ne le découvre que
le 26 je n'en sais rien pas dans la tête
du ministère étrangères simplement j'ai
lu une brève dans le canard enchaîné qui
expliquait que la direction de la
coopération internationale qui est un
service qui dépend du ministère de
l'intérieur avait été informé de
certains de mes déplacements à
l'étranger
voilà et qu'il n'avait pas fait remonter
l'information
moi en tout cas je peux vous affirmer
que j'ai informé des personnes qui
devaient en connaître par courtoisie
encore une fois la présidence je les
fais en mon nom propre en ma
responsabilité concernant les autres
acteurs se soient des ministres ou des
responsables d'administrations je ne
sais pas quels ont été leurs démarches
ou pas est la dernière question par les
informations vous pouviez avoir ou
donner ce que vous n'aviez pas
indisposer la sphère administrative ou
technocratique
je vous remercie de me donner cette
chance de pouvoir expliquer de manière
publique est très claire et sous serment
je ne détient aucun secret aucun secret
sur qui que ce soit je ne fais aucun
chantage
on essaye d'expliquer un certain nombre
de dysfonctionnements de la part de
l'état un certain nombre de négligences
et d'erreurs et de fautes de ma part que
je reconnais devant vous que je reconnus
devant la justice et j'assume mes
responsabilités
il faut pas en déduire que tout ça
au final est due à un secret ou des
secrets que je détiendrait je ne détient
aucun secret j'avais une fonction clair
que je vous ai exposé 19 septembre
j'ai rempli ma mission de manière claire
et je ne suis pas parti avec des secrets
sur qui que ce soit et j'essaye juste de
reprendre une vie normale et de me
refaire par moi-même sans demander
l'aide de personne voilà monsieur
sénateurs ce que je voulais vous dire
merci monsieur benalla madame benbassa
merci pour les détenteurs de passeport
diplomatique ou de service
une note verbale du ministère des
affaires étrangères est demandée pour
l'obtention du visa d'entrée sur le sol
tchadien
j'ai le document ici je précise que
cette formalité est demandé dans le cas
de court séjour comme de longs séjours
ma question est simple messieurs benalla
aviez-vous à disposition cette note
verbale pour l'entrée sur le sol
tchadien
comment avez vous pu produire un tel
document est ce que le quai d'orsay vous
a délivré une telle note pour obtenir le
visa
si vous n'aviez pas ce document
expliquez-nous pas quels moyens
vous avez pu obtenir votre visa alors je
vous délivre ce document si vous voulez
le voir
deuxièmement je voudrais savoir si c'est
possible
qui vous a restitué les passeports en
octobre et troisièmement vous avait
révélé dans la presse avoir eu des
contacts avec le président de la
république jusqu'au 24 décembre par
télégramme vous vos échanges était-il
privé ou d'une nature plus officielle et
daniel question votre épouse était
salariée de la reine au début des
affaires vous concernant pouvez vous
nous dire quels étaient ses fonctions
est elle toujours salarié
de la reine avez vous vous même encore
des contacts ou des fonctions avec le
parti présidentiel merci donc c'est ben
ben ali merci mais la sénatrice pour vos
questions je n'ai pas connaissance de
cette note verbale
je suis rentré au tchad oui mais je n'ai
pas connaissance de cette note verbale
je suis rentré au tchad sans visa
simplement avec un tampon et une
délégation économique étrangère ce que
j'avais déjà précisé donc j'écoute et je
suis rentré au tchad deux sens il faudra
peut-être poser la question à d'autres
autorités mais moi je ne sais pas je
n'ai pas fait de demande de visa pour
aller au tchad sur votre deuxième
question excusez moi j'ai par deuxième
question c'est
vos contacts la teneur de vos contacts
avec
la présidence lors de vos échanges par
un télégramme
est-ce qu'ils étaient privés ou d'une
nature plus officielle je ne commente
pas les articles de presse encore une
fois tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que je n'ai plus de contact avec qui que
ce soit à la présidence de la république
ou au parti de la république en marche
depuis le 24 décembre et la question sur
votre épouse qui était salariée de la
règle est elle toujours
je pense que ma femme n'a pas grand
chose à voir avec toute cette histoire a
donc je ne parlerai pas de ma famille si
je vous remercie
est-ce que je peux avoir le déclinant
monsieur pilet merci monsieur le
président je vénère là si je vous avais
posé la question que je pensais pouvoir
vous poser dès le départ je crains que
vous ne me répondiez que vous ne pouviez
pas répondre à raison de vos la
procédure pénale aussi je vais modifier
le caractère de celle ci je voulais vous
poser la question de savoir si quelles
étaient les raisons pour que vous ayez
sollicités ou en tout cas pour qu'on
vous ait attribué quatre passeports en
même temps mais je vais ex l'extraire
totalement dugas benalla et vous poser
la question suivante est-ce qu'il est
habituel que pour des personnes
remplissant les missions telles que vous
nous avez dit les remplir et style
habituel d'avoir quatre passeports en
même temps à quoi ça sert de ben ali
alors concernant
non c'est pas 4 passeport on sait
toutefois pas ce port le premier
passeport de service et ayant été
attribués en 2016 dans le cadre d'autres
fonctions et dont la restitution n'a
jamais été demandé non plus à cette
occasion il est habituel je pense que
les affaires étrangères vous avez
répondu
c'est clairement sur le fait de détenir
deux passeports diplomatiques pour des
raisons de demande de visa c'est juste
fonctionnel en ce qui concerne le le
passeport de service je vous le répète
excusez moi de le répéter je l' ai
obtenu dans des conditions d'obtention
normale et pour des raisons normale et
il y a je devrais pas être affirmatif
sur la chose mais il ya des gens qui
détiennent plus de passeport
diplomatique que j'ai plein de détenir
et c'est quelque chose de normal partir
du moment où vous demander à
l'administration un certain nombre de
documents
c'est assez fluide les les contacts les
contacts entre les administrations sont
assez fluide si j'avais fait une demande
qui aurait paru bizarre ou ebay le
mystère l'intérieur n'aurait pas
délivrer le passeport en question voilà
merci madame lherbier oui monsieur le
président monsieur benalla quand vous
déplaciez là lors des vingt déplacements
vous étiez seul où vous étiez en
délégation est une autre question me
vient à l'esprit les fonctionnaires lors
des passages aux frontières temps à
l'entrée qu'à la sortie ne vous ont posé
aucune question ne vous ont pas n'ont
pas été surpris de quoi que ce soit
vis-à-vis de vos passeports bon chez ben
à la merci pour votre question madame la
sénatrice gens comme toi je vais
répondre à une question auxquelles je ne
suis pas obligé de répondre parce que ça
concerne mais des déplacements privés à
l'issue de mes fonctions je me suis
déplacé des fois seuls des fois en
délégation je peux vous donner les
détails exacts de ce déplacement
et mes passeport qui ont été utilisés à
une vingtaine de reprises et 23 fois
exactement pour être tout à fait exact
l'ont été pour justifier simplement de
mon identité au passage frontière ne
m'ont fait bénéficier donc un avantage
si ce n'est à deux reprises du fast
track au lieu d'avoir la carte premium
je passais plus rapidement et donc les
autres fois à une dizaine de fois je me
suis déplacé dans un avion privé donc
avec les avantages que cela procure mais
sans jamais facilité quelque chose je me
suis soumis à l'ensemble des contrôles
lors de ses déplacements sur le
passeport diplomatique ne vous immunise
absolument pas je suis passé aux
portiques de sécurité
mes bagages on est passé au sont passés
aux rayons x fois la france
tout à fait je vous remercie
je donne la parole à madame monsieur dur
merci monsieur le président monsieur bd
l'ats le porte parole du gouvernement a
évoqué des dysfonctionnements à l'elysée
ces dysfonctionnements sont au coeur de
notre travail parlementaire ils
constituent ils se constituent par des
faits les conditions d'attribution de
restitution de non restitution de larmes
de service des passeports du téléphone
théorème ils sont aussi constitués par
le la compréhension des mécanismes et
des circuits décisionnels à l'elysée les
interactions entre les différents
protagonistes de l'organisation
élyséenne nous avons appris que vous
auriez demandé au directeur de cabinet
de l'élysée de réécrire votre lettre de
démission parce que c'est vrai et est-ce
que par ailleurs il vous est arrivé
assez fréquemment de d'imposer ainsi
vous vu un monsieur strzoda et une seule
question si je comprends bien monsieur
le sénateur en ce qui concerne la lettre
de licenciement alors déjà je pour vous
informer de d'où elles sortent dans la
presse et c'est une pièce de la
procédure judiciaire en cours concernant
l'effet du 1er mai c'est une
exploitation de mon téléphone portable
don kelly un sms qui est envoyé à
monsieur strzoda où je lui dis que la
lettre qu'il a écrite n'est pas la
vérité
et que je signe la réalité des choses
je n'ai pas imposé mais vu j'ai juste
exercer un droit qui est le droit à la
vérité et la lettre de licenciement la
première mouture qui avait été écrit par
monsieur strzoda indiqué que personne
n'était au courant que j'étais parti en
stage d'observation à la préfecture de
police le 1er mai ce qui malheureusement
n'était pas la réalité
donc j'assume mes responsabilités et je
les assume
quand la réalité est écrite
si on écrit un mensonge je le dénonce et
je veux juste vous faire constater que
le courrier ait été modifié et qu'il a
suivie la réalité des faits c'est à dire
que mes autorités étaient au courant que
j'avais le 1er mai en tant qu
observateur sur la manifestation
je vous remercie madame mercier merci
monsieur le président monsieur benalla
vous avez déclaré dans la presse que
vous étiez resté en lien avec le
président de la république jusqu'au 24
décembre
vous avez dit que la teneur de vos
échanges étaient sur des faits sociétaux
comment vous voyez là les choses les
filets jaunes etc
cela se serait passé par sms en nous
avons compris que le téléphone théorème
le téléphone crypté avait été désactivé
le 4 octobre
donc est ce que cela veut dire que vous
échanges ont eu lieu avec un téléphone
que je qualifierais de base donc que le
président de la république utilise un
téléphone commun pour monter je vous
remercie madame la sénatrice pour votre
question j'ai eu un certain nombre des
changes avec un certain nombre de
personnes sur des messagerie crypté
alors je pense que c'est un fake est
sorti dans la presse depuis le début du
mandat
et depuis le début de la campagne je
n'ai jamais eu des échanges avec le
théorème depuis le 1er juillet avec qui
que ce soit merci de cette réponse
monsieur le président caennais re
monsieur bénard je voudrais revenir sur
les déclarations de monsieur le drian
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères le 16 janvier dernier
monsieur le ministre nous disait que le
26 juillet à 2018 une demande officielle
de restitution de vos passeports
pratique vous avez été adressées et que
l'accusé réception avait bien été retiré
le 10 septembre puisque manifestement
vous n'aviez pas obtempéré une nouvelle
lettre vous parvenez et celle ci n'était
pas retiré entre temps le 1er août vous
avez été licencié et vous nous avez dit
tout à l'heure que pendant quelques
jours si j'ai bien compris vous aviez
utilisé vos passeports diplomatiques
pour cette mission privée dont vous ne
voulez pas évoquer le contenu
ma question est simple il y en aura une
deuxième tout à l'heure
comment vos passeports sont ils revenus
à l'elysée puisque le 19 septembre
vous nous affirmiez que ces passeports
était à l'elysée et permettez moi de
vous dire que semblerait que vos propos
était plus nette que ce que vous avez
déclaré tout à l'heure première question
deuxième question plus factuel
connaissez-vous un personnage qui
s'appelle philippe ababou solomons
monsieur banana
excusez moi concernant votre question
elle concerne la restitution du
passeport c'est bien ce à dire que vous
avez utilisé pendant quelques jours mois
d'août si j'ai bien compris
du 1er au 7 août pourrait tout à fait
c'est tout et donc ils sont repartis à
l'elysée commence quand il repartit est
ce que vous êtes passé l'elysée monsieur
strzoda nous ayons dit que vous n'y
avait pas mis les pieds à l'elysée à
compter du 1er août
les propos de monsieur strzoda sont pas
tout à fait exacts mais sans rentrer
dans des précisions qui encore une fois
concerne l'information judiciaire en
cours j'ai fait redéposer un certain
nombre d'effets personnels dont mais
passeport diplomatique à un personnel
salarié de l'elysée courant du mois
d'août plutôt vers la fin août
d'ailleurs c'est pour la première
question
la deuxième question je connais monsieur
philippe ababou sur le monde tout à fait
et je l' ai connu après mes fonctions au
mois de octobre 2018 pour être tout à
fait exact
je souhaitais rouge merci monsieur le
président monsieur vidal à une question
toute simple
vous nous dites que vous avez récupéré
les passeports début les passeports
diplomatiques début octobre
question vraiment simple pourquoi les
acceptez vous alors que manifestement il
était en lien avec des fonctions que
vous n'exercez plus ça c'est la première
question la deuxième mais je crains que
vous ne souhaitez vous ne souhaitiez pas
y répondre
puisque vous êtes dans le cadre d'une
enquête préliminaire sur faux et usage
de faux
ce qui ne vient pas contrevenir
l'activité de la commission denquête
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
déclaration de monsieur strzoda sur la
fabrique d'infos de votre part pour
demander un passeport de service au
ministère de l'intérieur
monsieur benalla
oui donc sur la restitution des
passeports c'est l'erreur que j'ai
reconnu que je reconnais encore une fois
devant vous je pense que moralement il
aurait été plus prudent de les laisser
dans le sac plastique
ça n'a pas été fait c'est une bêtise et
je les assume à 100 % en ce qui concerne
votre deuxième question le seul constat
que je fais c'est que n'ait pas été mis
en examen sur les qualifications de faux
et d'usagé de faux
je n'ai pas d'autres déclarations à
faire concernant les propos de monsieur
strzoda je vous remercie de cette
réponse monsieur marc merci président
monsieur benalla il apparaît que lorsque
vous avez intégré le cabinet de la
présidence de la république
vous n'avez pas fait de déclaration à la
haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique
vous auriez dû le faire puisque les
textes en la matière nous avons bien
regardé ils sont très claires y at il
quelqu'un qui à l'elysée vous a dit que
vous auriez dû faire et cette
déclaration à laquelle nous sommes
astreints nous les parlementaires ou
toutes personnes gravitant par exemple
au tour de l'exécutif ou des exécutifs
aujourd'hui vous allez faire une
déclaration à la commission de
déontologie et ce six mois après que
vous ayez quitter vos fonctions à
l'elysée
à quel moment et qui vous a demandé ou à
exiger de vous que vous fassiez cette
déclaration est pourquoi avoir mis
autant de temps à l'arrêt d'hygiène un
merci monsieur le sénateur pour votre
question en ce qui concerne la
déclaration préalable d'entrer à
l'elysée à la haute autorité pour la
transparence dans la vie publique
la sphère pseudo affaire benalla a
révélé le fait que les chargés de
mission n'y ont jamais été astreint et
ce était une pratique courante depuis un
certain nombre de quinquennats et que
dès lors que il ya eu cette affaire le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république a demandé aux neuf autres
chargés de mission de remplir cette
déclaration je tiens à vous informer que
inde issus de mes fonctions au mois de
septembre j'ai rempli une déclaration de
fin de fonction à la haute autorité pour
la transparence dans la vie publique
et en ce qui concerne la commission de
déontologie pour la fonction publique
j'ai pris connaissance de cette
obligation encore une fois trois jours
avant l'audition de monsieur patrick
strzoda devant vous qui m'a envoyé un
courrier dont je pourrais que je
pourrais vous fournir
éventuellement si vous en avez besoin où
il m'indiquait que c'était très
important de saisir cette commission est
malheureusement je n'ai pas relu mon
contrat de travail a déçu de mes
fonctions j'en suis absolument désolé
c'est encore une erreur de ma part
il est vrai que ce courrier aurait
certainement pu vous être adressées plus
tôt par exemple au mois de juillet ce
qui ne vous dispense est pas d'exécuter
vos obligations
madame eustache brinio mais derrière
j'ai bien noté dans les buts vos propos
que vous confirmiez que vous aviez
laissé vos passeports à l'elysée vous
refuser de répondre à la question qui
êtes vous les a rendus et comment ils
vous ont été restitués ça j'ai bien noté
cela aussi voilà une question que kim
qui m'interpelle vous avez été licencié
le 24 août avec 24 juillet pendant avec
un effet au 1er août
on est d'accord pourquoi vous avez
continué à utiliser des passeports
diplomatiques pourquoi comme tous les
citoyens de ce pays
vous n'avez pas utilisé un passeport
ordinaire comme moi j'en ai un pour
faire vos déplacements à quel niveau
avez vous estimez que votre passeport
diplomatique était nécessaire pour vous
déplacer
on peut se déplacer avec un passeport
ordinaire on passe les frontières
peut-être avec un peu plus de temps mais
on les passe donc qu'est ce qui
justifiait que vous avez absolument
voulu utiliser des passeports
diplomatiques pour ses déplacements et
c'est toujours très très simple de
vaines et aucune nécessité de
l'utilisation de ces passeports et je le
répète encore une fois c'était une
bêtise une erreur de ma part et ça ne
m'a pas facilité la vie plus que ça au
passage contrôle frontière j'ai échappé
à aucun contrôle
ce soit contrôles d'identité bagages etc
voilà c'était une erreur de ma part
monsieur le comte
oui merci monsieur le président je
voudrais monsieur benalla vous faire
préciser quels lots les changes que vous
avez
notre collègue madame benbassa sur votre
entrée au tchad 3 questions
la première est ce que vous êtes rentré
au tchad avec votre passeport
diplomatique sans visa comme vous ne
l'avez dit ou est-ce que vous avez
présenté au aux autorités tchadiennes un
passeport qui n'était pas diplomatique
deuxième question est ce que vous avez
est ce qu'il ya eu des demandes de visa
sur votre passeport diplomatique
depuis le 1er août le troisième question
est ce que vous êtes et ce que vous avez
voyagé avec votre passeport diplomatique
dans des pays où un passeport
diplomatique contrairement à un
passeport ordinaire est exempté de
demande de visa la première réponse je
suis rentré au tchad avec ce passeport
diplomatique
je n'ai jamais fait de demande de visa
avec ce passeport diplomatique
mais ce ne l'est pas fait madame et on
m'a acceptée au tchad
donc faudrait demander la poser la
question aux autorités tchadiennes
savoir pourquoi ils m'ont laissé rentrer
mais en tout cas je n'ai pas été refoulé
à la frontière et en ce qui concerne le
voyage dans des pays qui exempte le
passeport diplomatique de visage je ne
vais pas faire par ma connaissance
monsieur benalla la sortie de france
personnes dans les services la police de
l'air et des frontières ou à la douane
ne s'est opposé à l'utilisation de votre
passeport diplomatique à aucun moment
monsieur le président bat donc vous
l'avez utilisées pour sortir
il m'est arrivé de l'utiliser je vous
remercie
monsieur loïc hervé monsieur le
président monsieur vous nous avez dit
tout à l'heure à voir restituer à un
pin's
est ce celui du gspr par ailleurs
collaborateur du président de la
république
vous bénéficiez d'une habilitation
secret défense au terme d'une enquête
menée par le sgdsn
quand avez-vous rempli et signé le
formulaire de demande combien de fois
quand et par qui
avez vous été auditionné pour obtenir
votre accréditation de secret défense et
enfin le début et la fin de votre
accréditation secret défense ou dont ils
été notifiés si oui quand alors si ben
ali en ce qui concerne le pin's j'ai
entendu aussi beaucoup de choses et lu
beaucoup de choses dans la presse en
aucun cas le pin's qui est porté par les
membres du cabinet de la présidence de
la république n'est similaire à celui du
gspr le pin's du j'espère est un pin's
noir avec les armoiries de la présidence
et 3 étoiles qui signifie c'est
l'acronyme de la protection rapprochée
le pink qui est délivré aux membres du
cabinet et ainsi qu'à certaines
personnes des services administratifs
comme les photographes les intendants
qui met ce pin cela pourrait être
identifier plus facilement lors des
déplacements du président de la
république est un pin's rompt avec les
couleurs bleu blanc rouge et la mention
présidence de la république dessus il
est numéroté et il est attribué
nominativement par le commandement
militaire du palais de l'elysée sur
instruction du directeur de cabinet en
ce qui concerne l' enquête
d'habilitation elle n'a pas été
effectuée par le sgdsn le sgdsn effectué
les enquêtes simplement pour les
habilitations très secret défense ce
dont je n'étais pas habilités j'ai été
habilités par mon autorité d'emploi
c'est-à-dire le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république sur rapport
de la dgs et la direction générale de la
sécurité intérieure dont je pense que
les enquêtes sont assez poussées et dont
je ne connais pas la nature
c'est par essence le but quand on
procède à des enquêtes de ce type là en
ce qui concerne la notification d'une
feinte d'habilitation l'habilitation
étant donné dès lors que vous occuper
des fonctions à la fin de vos fonctions
lé cas du elle devient caduque et c'est
le cas dans l'administration
quand quelqu'un est sur un poste
qui nécessite une habilitation secret
défense et qu'il quitte ce poste pour
prendre une nouvelle fonction il n'est
plus habilité comme il l'était avant
l'habilitation dépend du poste que vous
occupez monsieur hervé veut compléter ce
que vous voulez dire que vous n'avez à
aucun moment été auditionné entendu en
vue d'une habilitation secret défense au
démarrage de votre choix de l'elysée
alors sans trahir de secrets en ce qui
concerne les habitations ce que moi même
je n'en suis pas détenteurs la seule
fois où intervient une audition dans le
cadre d'une habilitation s'est dès lors
qu'il ya un problème dès lors qu'il y a
un problème qui est soulevée par les
services dont ils viennent ils vous
demandent de répondre à une convocation
qu'elle voudrait déferré et répondre à
un certain nombre de questions qu'ils se
posent sur des failles susceptibles de
vous un pacte est donc n'ayant pas été
auditionné par ses services c'est qu'il
n'y avait aucune raison de douter
ou en tout cas de mme auditionné sur des
faits qui auraient été portées à leur
connaissance
madame 3 engley merci monsieur le
président monsieur ben alla vous nous
avez dit le tout à l'heure quand on a la
question a été posée sur le téléphone
théorème que vous aviez le souci du
respect des procédures
ma question porte sur la le moment où
vous avez récupéré vaut au passeport
diplomatique
vous nous avez dit que pour vos
déplacements il vous arrive est
d'informer des personnes très haut
placées à l'elysée de vos déplacements
est-ce que c'était lié à une procédure
et je m'en explique
est ce qu'on vous a demandé est ce que
quelqu'un vous a demandé de tenir
informé de vos déplacements
sinon qu'est-ce qui a pu vous motiver
qu'est-ce qui a pu expliquer votre
démarche auprès de ces personnes
sinon que le président de la république
en soient informés je vais jusqu'au bout
de ma question peut-être ce n'est pas du
tout votre démarche
et est-ce que vous avez infirmer ces
personnes lorsque vous êtes allés au
tchad
tu veineux là non pour répondre à votre
question
j'avais aucune obligation d'informer la
présidence de la république de mes
déplacements je les fais par courtoisie
et paradoxalement je les fais pour
éviter ce qu'on est en train de vivre
aujourd'hui
et l'erreur de ma part de l'utilisation
des passeports n'a pas aidé en soi à
l'idée c'était que quand je me déplace
connaissant la notoriété qu'a provoqué
un peu cette affaire qu' il n'y a aucune
interprétation du à ses déplacements en
l'occurrence je n'avais pas été informé
du déplacement presse du président de la
république trois semaines après le mien
au tchad et l'elysée a été informé de ce
déplacement au tchad
postérieurement à ce que je vais
effectuer
serge et je suis allé au tchad et je les
ai informés que j'avais été au chat je
les ai pas informé avant d'y aller c'est
ce qu'a provoqué ensuite toute cette
histoire
voilà mais je n'avais aucune obligation
à le faire je les fais par courtoisie
voilà madame traîne les voulait rebondir
vous l'avez fait par courtoisie pour que
le président de la république en soit
informé monsieur ménard
non je les fais surtout pour que les
services soient informés et que
l'entourage du président de la
république le soit également de manière
à ce qu' il n'y ait pas de conclusion
est qu'on soit un minimum au courant de
ce que je faisais a déçu de mon
licenciement
monsieur fichiers oui merci monsieur le
président tu as voulu revenir simplement
quelques instants solistes du téléphone
théorème on nous a expliqué ici qu'il y
avait quatre mille 600 appareils en
fonctionnement à l'échelon national
une trentaine qui était au niveau de
l'elysée et que l'utilisation de ce
téléphone nécessité que le correspondant
est le même téléphone
donc on est sur quelque chose qui est
extrêmement cadré extrêmement précis et
je voudrais savoir si vous avez eu
l'utilisation fréquente de ce type de
téléphone et le cas échéant avec quel
type de correspondants et comment vous
expliquer qu'un téléphone aussi
important aussi rare cryptée puis cet
égard et pendant plusieurs semaines
voire mois et que vous le retrouviez par
hasard dans vos cartons
alors que vous nous paraissait par
ailleurs si soucieux d'être
professionnel et de bien utiliser le
matériel dû le rendre en temps voulu
c'est vrai que c'est quand même un outil
très précieux et rare alors c'est un
coup de finale
alors c'est un geste un outil comme vous
l'avez dit qu'il ya un coûter très cher
à l'état et qui est très peu utilisé
malheureusement alors qu'il est à la
disposition de toutes les personnes qui
en ont besoin moi je me déplaçais
j'organisais des déplacements j'étais en
lien avec des autorités préfectorales
des autorités de police donc j'en avais
une utilité et c'était avec ces
personnes n'a que j'ai changé en ce qui
concerne le pourquoi il appelle je n'ai
pas retrouvé par hasard j'ai retrouvé
parce qu'après avoir reçu le courrier du
directeur de cabinet et je voulais être
sûr et certain que je n'avais plus roulé
en ma possession appartenant à la
présidence de la république
donc je les retrouver par des recherches
de manière à pouvoir le rendre de
manière spontanée ce qui a été fait par
mon avocate
j'explique pas le fait qu' il se soit
rendu compte que ce téléphone n'était
plus à le mois d'octobre en tout cas moi
je n'ai jamais été informé ni sollicitée
par quiconque pour le restituer je les
fais de ma propre initiative
comme je lé fais pour les passeports
diplomatiques après l'éclatement du
scandale et via mon avocate
voilà ce que je peux vous dire monsieur
le sénateur merci monsieur bénin
monsieur françois noël buffet merci
monsieur le président et ce benalla vous
êtes licencié le 1er août 2018
vous bénéficiez de passeports
diplomatiques de service qui vous
donnent naturellement qu'ils sont liés à
votre fonction pendant la période du 1er
août au 31 décembre vous voyagez 20 fois
à 20 reprises 23 fois précisément vous
avez dit tout à l'heure voyager à titre
personnel pour mener des missions
personnel dont vous considérez
d'ailleurs qu'elle ne regarde pas la
commission ce qu'on peut partager
naturellement on vous demande le
gouvernement en tous les cas vous
demande à deux reprises à partir du mois
d'octobre de restituer ces passeports
les lettres qui vous seront envoyées ne
seront pas retirés
vous ètes semble-t-il soucieux
de la régularité des choses vous l'avait
redit
trouvez vous normal cette situation de
voyager à titre personnel avec des
passeports qui était lié à la fonction
que vous n'occupez plus est ce que ça
vous paraît normal tv n'a alors juste
pour repréciser monsieur le sénateur ce
que je pense que vous êtes égaré au
niveau des dates
j'ai reçu les correspondances du
ministère des affaires étrangères à la
fin du mois de juillet 2018 plus un mail
du général bio farina qui me demandait
de restituer un certain nombre
d'affaires
j'ai restituer ses affaires dans le
courant du mois d'août 2018
et quand ces passeports ont été rendus
début octobre 2018
je n'ai après plus jamais reçu de
relance de la part du mystère de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères on
m'a rendu ces passeports en l'état
utilisable sans aucune interdiction de
les utiliser si ce n'est un cardan que
je qualifierais de morale et dont
j'assume la responsabilité aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que c'était une bêtise de
les utiliser donc ce n'est pas normal et
vous avez raison de le souligner
monsieur le sénateur ce n'était pas
normal d'utiliser ces passeports
je les fait et j'en assume la
responsabilité devant vous et devant la
justice également merci de votre réponse
vous souvenez peut-être également sans
doute l'avez vous appris que le 10
septembre 2018 la cheffe du bureau
compétents du ministère des affaires
étrangères vous a écrit un deuxième
courrier par lettre recommandée avec
accusé de réception
réception vous demandant de restituer
ses deux passeports et d'après ce qu'on
nous a dit ce courrier n'a pas été
retirée par vous même vous n'avez pas
trouvé l'argent n'est pas pris
connaissance il n'a pas été retirée et
c'était encore une période un peu
compliquée pour tout vous dire voilà je
vous remercie madame di folco merci
monsieur le président monsieur benalla
monsieur castanheira ministre de
l'intérieur nous a dit lors de son
audition le 16 janvier que vous aviez
fait une demande directement au quai
d'orsay pour obtenir un passeport de
service il vous aurait été refusée parce
que cette demande doit émaner de
l'employeur vous auriez donc à leur
produit un document rédigé par vous même
sur un papier à en-tête du chef de
cabinet document non signé donc s lusage
de faire un faux documents pour arriver
à ses fins pourquoi avez vous besoin
vraiment de ce passeport de service fin
juin 2018 alors que vos missions avaient
été considérablement réaménagé et donc a
priori plus besoin de vous déplacer avec
le président de la république à
l'étranger et je me permettrait aussi de
vous demander si vous avez produit un
faux document à ce moment là on
avez-vous produits d'autres à d'autres
moments durant vos missions sur un
assist
mes chers collègues que je ne crois pas
que monsieur benalla puisse nous
répondre sur le fait qu'il aurait ou non
produit des faux documents pour le coup
j'ai rappelé tout à l'heure quelle était
l'étendue de notre mission à monsieur b
n'a lui même
je comprends votre préoccupation et
d'ailleurs vous n'êtes pas la seule à
l'avoir mais ce sont des questions
susceptibles d'être tranchée par la
justice
même si comme monsieur benallal a relevé
s'agissant de son passeport de service
il n'a pas été mis en examen de ce chef
là
quant à son passeport diplomatique il
n'a jamais été allégué qu'il aurait
commis
faut du moins je l'ignorais les
rapporteurs
aussi il a juste été souligné que ce
passeport diplomatique lui a été
renouvelée suite à une demande qu'il a
fait lui même est alors que normalement
c'est le service du protocole qui fait
les demandes de renouvellement des
passeports diplomatiques des
collaborateurs du président de la
république sur un sujet et ça n'a pas
été le cas
mais monsieur benalla et qui lui a une
conception extensive de duchamp de ce
qui relèverait exclusivement de la
justice n'a pas voulu nous répondre sur
ce point alors même qu'aucun soupçon ne
pèse sur lui à cet égard en revanche sur
les passeports de service
un soupçon pèse sur lui puisque le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république a déclenché la procédure de
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
sur ce sujet pour lequel monsieur
benalla n'est à ce jour pas mis en
examen
donc monsieur b dallas alors vous pouvez
répondre merci mme chan inquiétant dans
la mesure où vous le souhaitez
juste pour rebondir sur votre propos est
pour répondre partiellement en tout cas
la question qui m'a été posée tout à
l'heure ce n'est pas le service du
protocole qui prend la décision
d'octroyer ou passeport diplomatique
ils vont juste les demandes démarches
administratives sur instruction du
cabinet du président de la république
évidemment mais il est exact aussi que
ce renouvellement n'a pas été demandée à
travers le service du protocole cette
fois ci en tout cas il a été
suffisamment considérer pour pouvoir
donner lieu à une délivrance normal oui
c'est ce qu'a pensé le ministère des
affaires étrangères exactement
voilà nous avait informé le service du
protocole tout à fait qu'il n'a pas vu à
les revoir quand elle a des mains mais
vous même je n'avais pas eu l'idée que
il n'y avait pas de justification compte
tenu de l'évolution de vos fonctions à
une demande de passeport diplomatique je
vous dis justement que j'ai répondu
partiellement à votre question monsieur
le président bah j'en suis désolé mais
j'ai répondu partiellement à votre
question c'est ce que ce n'est pas le
service du protocole qui prend la
décision d'octroyer ou de délivrer un
passeport diplomatique
ils ont un rôle de transmetteur entre la
présence dans le public et le quai
d'orsay
il savait pas nous aligner a transmis la
demande de renouvellement exactement
très bien il a reçu juste l'information
que le passeport avait été renouvelé oui
voilà vous même vous avez fait votre
demande directement au quai d'orsay
c'est pas exactement comme ça que ça
s'est passé comment ça cela s'est il
passé je le dirai la juge d'instruction
mais peut-être qu'elle ne vous le
demandera pas tandis que vraiment je
vous le demande
la question m'a déjà été posée en garde
à vue pour tout vous dire oui et c'est
pas une raison pour ne pas répondre mais
je veux c'est être partie de
l'information je reconnais je reconnais
que je reviens sur un aspect de nos
échanges pour vous donner une ultime
chance je comprends que je préside et
c'est je le fais en réalité avec
bienveillance monsieur dallo j'imagine
bien et c'est pour ça que je préférerais
répondre à la justice devant lequel il
ya d autres choisissent et à qui vous
préféré répondre tout à fait bien je
vous en donne acte je ne peux pas faire
autrement dans le cadre des textes et
dans le cadre des textes je suis là je
suis tout de même obligé de vous
rappeler les dispositions
la personne qui refuse de déposer devant
une commission denquête est passible de
deux ans d'emprisonnement et de 7500
euros damende d'entre nous auront à
délibérer bien sûr de la manière dont
vous nous avez répondu ou plutôt de la
manière dont vous ne nous avez pas
répondu à des questions dont je vous
redis que j'estime qu'elle relève de
notre commission denquête même si la
question qui vous est posée par
quelqu'un d'une information judiciaire
tout est oui mais le juge d'instruction
vous apposez certainement aussi beaucoup
d'autres questions sur des faits pour
lesquels vous répondez à nos questions
les faits qui sont qui font l'objet de
la justice sont abordés sous un angle
différent mais ce sont en partie les
mêmes faits que ceux sur lequel nous
mettons en oeuvre nos investigations
c'est donc bien normal qu'un juge
d'instruction vous pose des questions
dans un domaine pour lequel il n'estime
pas devoir engager des poursuites et que
nous posions aussi des questions sur ces
faits mais j'ai dit j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de vous expliquer ça je suis
persévérant et vous vous êtes d'obstiné
si bien que nous n'arriverons pas à
déboucher sur une réponse qui paraît
très satisfaisant j'ai dans la
commission dans lequel je le comprends
bien monsieur le président votre souci
j'ai juste un seul souci c'est celui de
la présomption d'innocence et de là je
donne un genre de la note aux
incriminations et à partir du moment où
je suis né vous auto akrimi donc à
partir du moment où je vous parle sous
serment
il ya des choses que je ne peux pas vous
dire mais mais il ya des noms se sont
pas des propos mensongers contrairement
à ce que vous dites madame la co
rapporteurs n'ya pas mais d'où vient le
banana c'est mon droit
c'est mon droit et il faut juste le
respecter partir du moment où une
information judiciaire est ouverte
contre vous quel que soit votre statut
il ya des choses que vous pouvez dire
d'autre que vous ne pouvez pas dire et
je suis là soucieux monsieur les sur
l'a20 sur trois sachets le seul endroit
que la manière dont ces débats ont eu
lieu tout à fait est bien entendu
simplement je vous dis qu'il ya des
questions auxquelles je ne peux pas vous
répondre et que je réserve sérémé
réponse à la justice et j'en suis désolé
je fais un choix qui est celui qui
aimait conseillé par mes avocats
reprenait tous puissent y ont aussi
interprété je veux dire non aux réponses
bien entendu david de nos prérogatives
constitutionnelles bien entendu et nous
interroger sur les raisons profondes de
cette mort est bien entendu mais je veux
madame di folco je jetterai pas encore
comme les fruits excusez moi madame
paule que vous devez compléter sa
question
merci monsieur le président moi aussi je
suis un peu insistante mais si vous ne
pouvez pas répondre à l'ensemble de mes
questions peut-être quand même pourriez
vous répondre à
en partie pourquoi aviez vous besoin le
28 juin 2018 d'un passeport de service
alors d'un passeport diplomatique le vin
ge passport de service ah non pardon le
jeu du jeu c'est vous qui avez raison
monsieur cours d'un passeport de service
j'ai raison parce que j'ai pris des
notes d'un passeport de service alors
que vos fonctions avait été modifié
pourquoi aviez vous besoin d'un
passeport de service le 28 juin au point
d'en faire une demande
même hors cadre juste madame la
sénatrice je soulève que votre question
de tout à leur pose quand même la
question de la présomption d'innocence
et je vous fais remarquer juste je vous
fais je vous fais remarquer
juste après que le président ballet fait
également que je n'ai pas été mis en
examen sur les faux et usage de faux
oui alors attendez je vais essayer de
donc les motifs des nanas je reprends
aviez-vous encore pour l'exercice de
fonctions réellement besoin d'un
passeport de service le 28 juin dernier
si la question vous est posée nous
laissons totalement de côté le point de
savoir si vous avez demandé ce passeport
de service au moyen de ce que le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république a qualifié de faux ou pas
nous laissons de côté cette question
intégralement nous vous demandons si une
égard à la fonction que vous exerciez
alors il était justifié de disposer d'un
passeport de service et je vais vous
faire la même réponse parce que ça fait
trois fois que vous me posez la question
il ya une information judiciaire qui est
en cours
j'ai reçu ce passeport de la manière la
plus normale du monde
oui et c'est monsieur là c'est curieux
tout de même que vous vous abritez
derrière la mission de la justice
en vérité quand ça vous arrange mais
vous avez fait tout à l'heure un long
dégagement sur les actes qui vous sont
reprochés le 1er mai pour les justifier
alors là vous parlez d'une question que
nous ne vous avons même pas posée qui
relève intégralement de la justice et
vous ne vous privez pas de porter une
appréciation sur le rôle que vous avez
eue et sur la justification de ce rôle
au regard d'un article du code pénal que
vous nous avez rappelé là pour le coup
la justice elle a beau être saisie vous
êtes tout à fait à l'aise pour entrer
dans des détails que nous vous ne nous
vous demandons pas et quand nous vous
posons des questions qui ont trait à
votre mission à l'elysée et aux raisons
pour lesquelles vous pourriez avoir un
passeport de service
alors là vous vous abritez derrière une
information judiciaire alors même que
comme je les dis comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même vous n'êtes pas mise en examen
malgré l'article 40 qui a été utilisé
par le directeur de cabinet du président
de la république donc véritablement il
ya dans la manière dont vous utilisez le
travail de la justice des contradictions
de semble-t-il comme vous l'avez
souligné qui a été révélé par l'article
40 qui fort opportunément a été rendu
public devant votre commission même
moment où le chef de cabinet était en
train de déposer devant les policiers à
la veille d'une garde à vue qui vous a
été annoncé donc ça aussi je pense qu'il
faudrait le soulever maintenant je pense
que j'ai le droit à une défense que
j'allais être entendu dans les toutes
prochaines heures donc c'est à peu près
c'était à peu près compréhensible en été
entre les fils et madame la sénatrice et
que aujourd'hui je pense que personne
ici n'est dans ma situation et donc j'ai
eu droit à une défense
j'ai le droit de ne pas moto incriminés
vous avez le droit de me poser beaucoup
de questions et moi je vous donne mes
réponses comme je l'entends jeu
c'est ce que c'est ce que nous
constatons donc vous mettez en oeuvre
votre stratégie de défense devant la
commission d' enquête du sénat qui elle
ne s'intéresse nullement à ceux dont la
justice est saisie
je vous remercie monsieur bigot merci
monsieur le président j'ai une question
fort simple monsieur bénard à savoir si
vous êtes en possession d'un passeport
ordinaire comme tous les français
peuvent en avoir et si oui pourquoi ne
l'avez vous pas fait usage
j'ai compris que vous disiez fait une
bêtise d'avoir utilisé par 23 fois le
passeport diplomatique
c'est toujours là une fois que l'on met
poursuivi qu'on se dit on a fait une
bêtise aurait mieux fait pas le faire
mais les passeports ne servent pas qu'à
passer les frontières
lorsqu'on est dans un pays et que l'on
veut comme vous l'avez fait rencontrer d
autres autorités
il est souvent utile d'avoir aussi un
passeport
je pense que pour accéder à la
présidence de la république d'un état
quelqu'un qui vous demandent quand même
des papiers sans doute que le passeport
diplomatique facilite de ce point de vue
là les contacts donc si vous aviez un
passeport ordinaire
pourquoi avez-vous fait usage de
passeports diplomatiques nous question
qui a déjà été posée mais à laquelle
vous pourriez apporter une réponse plus
précise peut-être alors j'ai un
passeport normal et d'ailleurs il a été
utilisé entre le 7 août et début octobre
2018 parce que je n'étais plus en
possession des passeports diplomatiques
ça c'est la première réponse à votre
première question
la deuxième réponse c'est que j'ai fait
une erreur je le répète pour la sixième
fois et que quand vous êtes non visite
dans un pays étranger
vous ne vous présentez pas devant le
bâtiment de la présidence de la
république en exhibant votre passeport
fort haut et clair pour dire je veux
être reçu par le président regardez j'ai
un passeport diplomatique
ça ne fonctionne pas tout à fait comme
ça vous vous présentez un contrôle
frontières pour justifier de votre
identité vous attestez de votre identité
et ensuite vous rentrez vous avez les
rendez-vous qui ont déjà été convenu à
l'avance vous en voyez pas non plus
il avec la photocopie du passeport que
vous dites n'est encore pour obtenir ce
type de rendez-vous sait pas exactement
comme ça que ça fonctionne et je vous
remercie madame marie b merci monsieur
le président je vais essayer de revenir
de manière un peu plus générique et aux
questions qui vous ont été posées
auxquelles vous ne voulez pas répondre
vous avez répondu tout à l'heure à
monsieur pilet que les passeports
avaient été délivrés normalement par
l'administration
donc nous pouvons en déduire qu'il était
normal en tant que responsable de
sécurité
que vous ayez trois passeports
diplomatiques et deux passeports de
service d'une manière générique en
faisant abstraction de votre cas et de
la procédure en cours
pouvez-vous au regard de ce qu étaient
vos fonctions expliqué les utilisations
respectives de ces deux types de
passeports services et diplomatiques et
les raisons et les procédures par
lesquelles ils ont été attribués une
deuxième question dans l'inventaire qui
vous a été demandé pour la demande de
remise des faits liés à votre fonction
sur la procédure de restitution de ces
pièces dans l'inventaire des pièces qui
faisont été demandé est-ce qu'il
figurait est-ce que figurer le téléphone
le téléphone crypté urbaine à la merci
madame la sénatrice pour votre question
je pense qu'elle a déjà été posée donc
je dans l'âme cadre je n'y répondrai pas
je n'étais pas responsable de la
sécurité
vous soulevez je crois bien avoir fait
un exposé assez précis lors de ma
première audition
j'avais un statut de chargés de mission
et des fonctions d'adjoint au chef de
cabinet du président de la république ce
qui n'est pas exactement la même chose
que responsable de la sécurité aux
gardes du corps comme je l'entends
encore régulièrement en ce qui concerne
la question de la restitution des effets
personnels
je tiens à préciser que le théorème
n'était pas inscrit sur le courrier de
patrick strzoda à mon intention bien que
non membre de notre commission de cieux
cédric perrin souhaite poser une
question je lui donne donc la parole
monsieur perrin merci monsieur le
président très rapidement juste pour
éclaircir un point vous avez expliqué
avoir eu non pas quatre mais trois
passeports diplomatiques si c'est bien
ce que j'ai entendu et vous avez fois de
plus allez vous expliquer que certains
n'étaient plus valables parce que enfin
vous les avez pas utiliser parce qu'il
n'était plus valable a priori lorsque
vous auriez plus vous vous déplacez avec
ma question est simple est-ce que ces
passeports diplomatiques vous avez pu en
avoir pris possession avant d'entrer à
la république en marche et avant
d'entrer à l'elysée
monsieur ben alla alors pour répondre à
votre question
j'ai eu était en possession de quatre
passeports de passeports diplomatiques
de passeports de service trois
passeports m'ayant été octroyés pendant
ma présence à la présidence de la
république pour être précis et je n'ai
jamais eu de passeport diplomatique
avant mes fonctions à l'elysée
monsieur jean pierre sueur si monsieur
le président quelques questions très
courte
en complément la première est très
simple monsieur benalla vous êtes vous
rendu à l'elysée depuis que vous avez
été licencié
je ne répondrai pas à cette question sur
le court à porter étant donné que
s'applique peut-être ou pas après avoir
quitté mes fonctions
mais alors monsieur sur veut savoir en
réalité si je ne me trompe pas si vous
avez poursuivi une forme de
collaboration avec la présidence de la
république après votre licenciement afin
de vérifier que ce licenciement a été
pleinement suivies d'effet je crois que
c'est le sens de la question de notre
reporter non ça dépend si on entend la
présidence de la république en tant que
bâtiment ou la présidence de la
république en tant qu'institution je ne
me suis jamais j'ai jamais eu de
collaboration professionnelle avec
l'elysée postérieure à mon licenciement
concernant la première concernant la
première réponse devront alors vous vous
ne dont vous ne répondez pas mais vous
fait un distinguo entre le bâtiment et
l'institution si je vous comprends bien
tout mais si vous voulez j'insiste sur
le fait que ce qui s'est passé après
votre départ fait partie strictement de
nos prérogatives pourquoi parce que vous
avez vous deviez et vous allez sans
doute faire une déclaration auprès de la
commission de déontologie
puisque dans les mois qui suivent une
haute fonction comme celle que vous avez
exercé
naturellement il est très important dans
l'intérêt de l'état qu'il ne soit pas
fait usage d'aucune façon de la fonction
précédente
au bénéfice d'une fonction suivante
c'est pourquoi après avoir pris note de
votre réponse il nous a été dit que vous
n'étiez pas venu vous ne dites pas que
vous n'êtes pas venu mais on ne sait pas
si vous êtes venu dans le bâtiment dans
l'institution peut-être dans
l'institution bien je voulais vous
parler encore une fois parce que voyez
vous nous aimons je vais dire ça
gentiment vous nous aimons les belles
histoires vous c'est tout le monde lit
des romans des histoires bon mais quand
même
nous sommes sous serment
vous menez une activité et je comprends
tout à fait vous ayez le souci de mener
une activité vous rencontrer monsieur
solomons et ils le trouvent sympathique
je suppose vous vous retrouvez après en
voyage avec lui et nous savons que ce
voyage est un voyage économique
d'ailleurs vous nous l'avez dit et il
n'y a rien de répréhensible en le fait
qu'il y ait des relations économiques
bien sûr et des organismes qui s'en
occupe et des entreprises qui s'en
occupent mais quand même vous êtes là
vous allez voir un deux trois quatre je
ne sais pas moi je ne compte pas chef
d'état c'est quand même pas anodin
après avoir été licencié de l'elysée
vous êtes dans des délégations et vous
êtes à titre personnel quand vous êtes
là parce que c'est votre liberté et être
là et vous êtes devant monsieur le
président du tchad et d'après ce que
nous avons compris mais peut-être ai-je
mal compris monsieur solomons s'occupe
de vendre paraît-il des uniformes des
vêtements militaires mais j'ai lu ça
comme vous dites dans la presse et je
sais que vous n'êtes de d'accorder pas
beaucoup de crédit à ce genre de
déclarations
mais vous avez à participer à cet
entretien là aussi vous pouvez ne pas
répondre mais est ce que vraiment lors
de cet entretien il n'aurait été
question que de cette activité marchande
est ce que vous êtes sûr que dans vos
déplacements
il n'a jamais été question d'aucune des
fonctions que vous avez exercé que vous
n'avez jamais été reçus en référence aux
fonctions vous avez exercé ou au motif
que vous pouviez jusqu'au 24 décembre
communiquer en particulier avec les
disait est ce que vous êtes sûr qu'il
n'y a aucun aspect dans les
conversations économiques qui sont
encore légitime qui auraient trait à des
questions liées à la défense ou à la
sécurité
est-ce que vous pouvez vous engager
devant nous sur ces questions sous
serment
ces belles à la merci monsieur le
co-rapporteur pour votre question
première remarque j'ai envie de tout
faire je ne vois pas le rapport entre le
licenciement et l'impossibilité d'être
reçu par un chef d'état étranger qui est
souverain et qui fait absolument ce
qu'il veut s'il a envie de me recevoir
s'il a envie de m'inviter à venir le
voir je vous en donne et s'il y avait
tout à fait raison sur le plan du droit
je vous remercie
et s'il a envie d'avoir une discussion
avec toutefois sauf si la commission de
déontologie n'a pas été saisis pour
s'assurer que nouvelle activité était
conforme aux règles déontologiques qui
sauf que la commission de déontologie je
ne pense pas qu'elle ait le pouvoir de
m'interdire de rencontrer des gens de
voyager et d'essayer de faire quelque
chose de ma vie et non pas de mettre
enfermée chez moi au fin fond de la
normandie on le touchant les allocations
emploi de pôle emploi
donc j'ai s'agit bien d'une
collaboration salariés que non non j'ai
eu une collaboration à partir du mois de
novembre
le salaire gelé perçu d'une société qui
s'appelle qui s'appelle france clause
protection qui massari pendant un mois
et à vous parler des vous parlez des
déplacements c'était à titre privé ou me
parler je veux juste être très précis va
avec monsieur le président bah je n'ai
pas eu l'occasion du déplacement avec
monsieur philippe ababou solomons perçu
une rémunération spécifiquement pour ce
voyage spécifiquement pour ce voyage au
tchad
donc je n'ai pas été emmené au tchad
contre rétribution pour faciliter
quelques quelconque la sphère que ce
soit contrairement à ce qui peut être
sous-entendu vous êtes rétribués par qui
et pourquoi
je pense que ça ne vous concerne pas
aujourd'hui monsieur le court annonceurs
ça me concerne je m'excuse
à partir du moment où l'on est dans les
six mois qui suivent l'exercice d'une
fonction importante
la loi prévoit une obligation de saisir
la commission de déontologie pour parler
des activités et que la commission
statue sur le fait qu'il n'y a aucun
rapport entre les activités que vous
exercez présentement et les missions qui
étaient les vôtres
il y a quelques mois au sein de la plus
haute institution
l'état alors ne vous énervez pas michèle
conchon s'est pas énervé je suis plein
de conviction elle savait bien tout le
monde le sait d'ailleurs parfait je vous
dise pénale sarsgaard sarsgaard
peut-être la commission de déontologie
qui va être saisi par mon avocat mais je
n'ai pas à vous dire aujourd'hui ce que
je fais de quoi je vis où je vis avec
qui et comment je me déplace je vois ces
questions nous on ne vous demande c'est
très subtil équilibre décrire votre
employeur et pour quelle activité dans
quels domaines nous avons le droit de le
demander puisqu'il ya un droit de suite
par rapport à ce que vous faisiez à
l'elysée et d'ailleurs je vais vous dire
quelque chose ça c'est pas couverts par
la justice et d'autre part se serait
très bien que vous répondiez parce que
dans ce cas nous aurions l'assurance
qu'il n'y a votre réponse nous donnerait
l'assurance qu'il n'y a aucun rapport
entre ce que vous faites présentement si
vous occuper d'un autre domaine
d'activité
on dira pas très bien bonne chance et
réussissait mais le fait que vous ne
répondiez pas engendre forcément le
soupçon et nous nous disons mais comment
pouvons nous être sûrs que ces voyages
que ces contacts n'est pas un rapport ni
avec ce que vous avez fait avant ni avec
les contacts que vous avez encore eu
jusqu'au jour de noël avec la présidence
de la république alors sauvé n'a là
encore une fois je pense que ça rentre
dans le périmètre de l'instruction ce
que j'ai pu faire comme déplacement à
quel titre et avec les passeports
diplomatiques et que deux
je pense que ma vie d'aujourd'hui me
concerne moi et seulement moi et que je
fais tout dans le respect des lois
depuis que j'ai rendu les passeports
diplomatiques ma vie privée et ma vie
professionnelle et je ne vais pas
répondre de manière perpétuelle à toutes
les questions qui me sont posées par les
journalistes dix fois par jour à savoir
qui je rencontre qui je vois ce que je
fais de qui je suis salarié je pense que
ça ça me regarde moi monsieur benalla
les questions qui vous sont posées ici
ne sont pas les questions des
journalistes et le statut de vos
réponses n'est pas le même que celui des
réponses que vous donnez quand vous
consentez vous même
des interviews dans la presse nous
allons nous en tenir là je vais vous
demander de bien vouloir vous retirer
ainsi que votre conseil et nous allons
poursuivre nos travaux
je vous remercie